followed you for a very long time and i
i really enjoy
the message that you put out and kind of
the the uh alert system that you've put
out
on the internet and elsewhere for
decades
over a decade now i've read your books i
have um
i i've followed your i've even bought
your hedge fund not your hedge fund your
mutual fund
and i'm trying to convince the the
university of california to invest all
of calpers
into your mutual fund even though you're
an alum of uc
berkeley and i'm here in uc san diego
you're bitter well it's the same
uc system so uh but you know
i have more than one fund so they can
diversify i have five funds right now
so they don't have to put it all in one
all right i'll tell that to president
drake i'm sure
he will be willing to do it now i want
to first before we go too deep into
bitcoin versus gold versus
commodities and stuff i want to ask you
a deep a deep question to begin with
peter because i know you're a
philosophical guy
i know you've had a lot of encounters
with with um
with the notions of the purpose of
wealth i want to ask you there's a
famous line
in um i think it's wall street part one
where
uh charlie sheen asked michael douglas
you know how many yachts
can you water ski behind i want to ask
you you've been incredibly successful
what is the purpose of wealth to you
peter schiff
well i think from a society perspective
because obviously on an individual basis
i mean it's pretty obvious
what the benefits of wealth are right i
mean we all want to be wealthy
uh you know because you know we want to
live a better life and
the more wealth we have you know the
more things that we can enjoy
uh in life that aren't free i mean some
things in life are free
but a lot of stuff uh isn't but i think
from
you know the benefit of society like how
do i benefit from somebody else's wealth
that is really the question and is
wealth something that we should fear
because the way the left spins it
wealth is a bad thing if you don't have
it and and somehow when somebody has
wealth
it's because they're they're hogging it
or they're they're taking wealth from
you that you're somehow poorer
because somebody else is richer and
nothing can be further from the truth
because first of all wealth is created
nobody just takes wealth
i mean unless you're a thief and you
steal something but as far as
most entrepreneurs they have to create
the wealth it wasn't there
until they created it's not like there's
all this wealth and we just grab a piece
of it
people have to create it and the wealth
is created
by doing things engaging an activity
that benefits mankind because
it's the productive capacity that is
you know coming from that wealth the
wealth in in
in factories and plant equipment uh
in you know all the things that you
create and things that you invent
that would constitute your wealth you
made that wealth by improving the lives
of
of other people in order to get it
and the fact that you now have wealth
you can continue to
use that wealth for the benefit of of of
humanity
uh even if that's not your goal your
goal is just to accumulate more wealth
the only way you can do that is by
enriching everybody else because that's
how
you benefit from your wealth you make it
available you invest
uh you you grow the economy and uh you
fund other people's businesses if you're
no longer funding your own
well peter can you just mute your um can
you just mute your
microphone oh oh you know what on the
clubhouse
volume down all right yeah yeah yeah
it's about muted
okay let me ask rockwell can you tell me
if it's still uh
uh being a problem on semi-attacks
rockwell is one of the moderators
should be okay i saw the red light over
here yeah so yeah so the creation of
wealth is often demonized but
but you know on a personal level
speaking you know
you amass great wealth i sometimes think
you've got kids that are very uh
devoted to you and and you know they
tease you and i follow
spencer and they become influencers and
you know we live on
as woody allen said do i want to live on
through my works no i want to live on
in my apartment so like given that what
do you want to do with this massive
wealth and army you have a shift
army that's out there and it's growing
every day and i count myself in the
legions although
we're gonna we're gonna do a little
battle with some of the uh some of the
hodlers
as we go on uh but uh but tell me what
what is your goal like you can't water
ski behind two yachts
you can't live to three thousand years
old what what do you personally
what is it yachts are not the greatest
for water skiing anyway you want a
smaller boat
uh you know they can go faster i guess
you could wake surf on a yacht if it has
a
big enough weight but uh you know you
but
um look i mean obviously
you know i i am accumulating
wealth the goal is you know
just so you know for me to have it or
for me to be able to
spend some of the money and leave money
to my children or their children
um so but but i recognize that
my activities um are benefiting others i
mean
if i didn't have any value to offer
others i would
never have accumulated anything at all
that's the whole beauty of it and that's
the point where
you don't want to try to tax wealth or
destroy wealth
wealth is really the seed corn that
makes the economy grow and you look at
all these
socialist countries where they've
attacked or redistributed wealth
uh they end up impoverishing everybody
you know
they don't just make the wealthy poor
they make everybody poor
and and you lose all of the benefits so
i mean that's why you know the
inheritance tax is
one of the worst taxes out there that
should be you know abolish the estate
tax it should be zero
you don't want to try to destroy wealth
that has accumulated you want to allow
that wealth
to continue and you know a lot of these
people these billionaires
they have so much more wealth than they
could possibly spend i mean all of this
wealth
is not uh you know the yachts that
they're water skiing behind i mean most
of that wealth is used
to continue to grow the economy
and invest in in productive efforts uh
some of it is used
to fund charitable giving or all sorts
of things that could not happen
absent uh that wealth
yeah yes you know one thing i want to
point out too because i know we're going
to talk about bitcoin later
but bitcoin ain't wealth i mean a lot of
people
you know look at oh i'm getting p look
at all the wealth that we've created in
bitcoin
no wealth has actually been created in
bitcoin
because bitcoin itself doesn't do
anything
it doesn't produce anything uh now there
are people
who are wealthier today because they own
bitcoin
but the bitcoin themselves
isn't adding i mean if all the bitcoins
vanished tomorrow
the world would be no worse off because
they were missing i mean it's not like
you know oh no we don't have those
bitcoin now
i mean yes the individuals who used to
own them would
would be upset that they no longer had
them
but a lot of people who are huddling and
you mentioned the huddlers right they
have all this so-called wealth on paper
yeah it's on paper right if if you
haven't sold any of your bitcoins
you haven't actually converted your
bitcoins to wealth but the only way you
can do that
right if you if you want to get actual
wealth and you want to sell your bitcoin
somebody has to buy it from you so
really what's happening is
their wealth gets transferred to you you
get their wealth and they get your
bitcoin
so bitcoin is a mechanism for
transferring wealth
from the people who uh
own it to the people who want bitcoin
and they're willing to exchange their
wealth for bitcoin
uh but the bitcoins themselves aren't
any wealth and eventually i think
you know the bubble pops and you know
today it hit 50 000 so it's you know a
new milestone
uh in the life of the bubble uh but uh
at some point all the air comes out and
all that paper wealth well you know
vanishes
yeah so you know you're meeting me for
the first time and it's asymmetric
warfare because i've known you for so
long
for so long but i'm a physicist i'm an
astrophysicist i study the origin of the
universe
and one of my heroes is galileo galilei
uh and yesterday was it would have been
his 457th birthday so
he's about 400 years older than you so
happy birthday to him
uh but uh i wanted to you know the first
question i was going to ask you
yesterday but i'm going to ask it to you
anyway
he has written some of the most valuable
books in human history
by virtue of the work that he put in to
understand the cosmos and specifically
physics but he also had a very small
book which is actually the rarest of all
his books published in 1600
and that book is called the it's
basically about a slide rule and back
then that was the iphone of the
generation very few people had slide
rolls but it allowed you to do
calculations
even faster than the abacus that i'm
sure you and i both use
uh but this slide rule he goes through
all the different things you can use it
for you can measure triangles you can do
length proportions you can make copies
of things but one thing you could do
is currency conversion and i want to uh
just read a very quick passage if you'll
indulge me
uh from this book he talks about leaving
behind what we can do
let us say we want to convert 180
gold scooty into venetian ducats
to do this to do this the only thing we
need to know beforehand when we don't
know the exact rate of the two
currencies
is how much each is worth when exchanged
for a third currency
soldi for for instance so he goes
through this whole thing and am i gonna
shake this guy because he died pretty
poor
he didn't have that much money he had a
bunch of illegitimate kids and ex-wives
and
uh mistresses that he had to support so
he had to be in a business i call it
galileo incorporated
but i want to shake him if i could go
back in time and say forget this you
know calculation and the slide rule
save one of these books because this
book will be worth a trillion scootie
because the scooty's worth nothing now i
mean you can get one
you know kind of as a showpiece but i
want to ask you well what was this
what was this scooty made of a scooty
was you know it was like either
some you know maybe a piece of copper or
some or or something i mean
it'd have to have some kind of value
even as a collectible i mean how many
could there still be
if they were that old i mean how many of
them could be around sure for sure but
the but these are the houses
there's only there's only 46 of these
books that are still well
yeah the books are probably even more
rare if they've survived
the elements i mean somebody would have
had to gone out of their way to preserve
it for it to sort of be around
yeah so when you look at somebody like
isaac newton another astronomer and
physicist
he uh spent most of his time you might
not know this but he was the master of
the mint
uh in the united kingdom and one of his
jobs was figuring out ways to torture
counterfeiters but he's the one who came
up with the idea of the fluted edge
on the edge of a coin to prevent
counterfeiting debasing
and uh yeah yeah so and that actually
had ripple effects it allowed the jews
that were living
in england to no longer be under
suspicion of of coin clipping etc
yeah and you know when the united states
mint decided to counterfeit the dimes
and the quarters
um and the half dollars it continued
that tradition
of of of having those ridges even though
there was nothing left to clip
because they took all the silver out and
they just uh took a bunch of copper
and uh you know cladded in nickel but
then they made it look like the old
silver coins
by putting the ridges on and so to me
that was
you know a pure counterfeit because it
was saying hey here's a quarter
even though there's not a quarter of a
dollar in here because a dollar was
defined as a weight of silver
and there was no silver in there so it
was a complete uh counterfeit coin
yeah that's right and and it's funny
that we call it a quarter a quarter of
water it was a quarter of an
ounce of silver and you can't get any
silver in any of these pieces of
well it was a quarter of a dollar yeah
but the dollar was defined by that's
what a dollar was it was actually a
measure of a weight of gold or silver
and that was actually legally spelled
out in the coinage act it was
1792 where they said you know how do you
define
a dollar it's so much gold and so much
silver
and so when i think about that you know
there's all this talk about in
blockchain
that the value of blockchain will get to
blockchain specifically later on
but is in so-called proof of work so how
much and
how much computation went into the
production
mining of a bitcoin and again we'll get
into bitcoin specifically
but i want to first take a mutual maybe
enemy of
of of people that are on the bitcoin
side and on the gold standard side of
the gold side as you
and i uh are um but against fiat and i
want to ask a question
when when i look at a piece of paper
that has in god we trust
it has pictures of dead presidents on it
and uh and it's backed by
some measure of work in the case of the
us dollar it's backed by nine
u.s carrier battle groups that cost
trillions of dollars to put together
like that took a lot of work
well that's not really i mean obviously
i mean the u.s dollar isn't technically
at this point or let's not call it the
u.s dollar because
that's not really what it is but there
are federal reserve notes
and and even though they're they're not
actually notes because a note is a
promise to pay
and at one point federal reserve notes
did promise to pay dollars
they no longer promised to pay anything
you know my father once
labeled them as greenies that's what he
called them in his book the biggest con
and by the way he was a big fan of
galileo because my father and galileo
both went to
jail not even though that they didn't do
anything wrong but
they still went to jail um but
the the greedies as my dad called them
they're they're not backed by anything
but
what they have that makes them viable
right and work as um
um money or you mean is that number one
they are legal tender so you know
everybody accepts them the government
requires that taxes be paid
in you know greenies
and every american who doesn't want to
go to jail
like has to accumulate this currency
in order to give it to the government so
you know my dad used to say if the
government said we're gonna
you know you have to pay your taxes in
peach pits and that's all we'll accept
then all of a sudden we'd all be
accumulating peach pits because we would
need them
in order to pay our taxes so there is a
need for dollars because
that's how you uh pay your taxes but
then beyond that
you have this long tradition where we're
using dollars i mean we've all grown up
with dollars everything we buy is priced
in dollars we have some idea
of what we think a dollar is worth in
terms of various products
our salaries are in dollars our rents
are in dollars our
insurance uh uh policies are in dollars
uh you know
everything that we do is dollarized and
so we have that tradition
and then we have confidence that i've
used dollars all my life i've always
been able to buy things with dollars
i always will be able to i recognize
that there's some inflation and that
over time
uh certain things are going to require
more dollars but
you know the dollar is going to lose
that value slowly in the meanwhile i can
invest my money i can try to beat
inflation
but so you have all that tradition right
none bitcoin doesn't have any of that
right it's like a fiat digital currency
but with no history of being used for
anything
nothing being priced in it no contracts
no bonds no insurance
no sovereign says i want my taxes paid
in bitcoin
uh and you know it's not using anything
it's not a commodity like
gold or silver or any other commodity
that is used
it's not an asset that throws off
dividends or income or rent i mean it's
nothing
but if people want to buy it then you
know
yes there is some artificially created
uh limit to the supply and there's no
limit to the demand so if demand keeps
going up and nobody wants to sell
the price can go up until nobody wants
to buy and then people want to sell and
the price crashes so
when is that going to happen i mean i
don't know obviously i'm not that smart
well i think you know there's there's
been a value and and i pointed out
you know to some of my friends are like
why are you having peter on you know
he's been wrong
they send you they copy your tweets you
know you should feel pretty pretty happy
you know i always feel like if
somebody's stalking you peter you know
you should feel pretty good people
really care about you
but but you know it's like relentless
people but
all they're saying is i'm wrong because
the price of bitcoin is going up
look i do admit that i didn't think
bitcoin would hit
50 000 although i said it was possible i
doubted it would happen
and so it happened right but i mean i
i've never
said that the price of bitcoin couldn't
go up i mean if people are dumb enough
to pay 50 000
maybe someone will be dumb enough to pay
a hundred thousand i don't know
i don't know how how stupid people are
gonna be i mean i'm tired of
you know i i generally overestimate the
intelligence of people
uh so yeah i i but i'm not wrong
if the price goes up you know but
if if you actually see bitcoin
actually being used as a medium of
exchange
then you can try to say hey look you're
wrong look here whole societies have
been have adopted bitcoin
that's their medium of exchange that's
their currency they don't use euros they
don't use dollars they're all using
bitcoin
show me where that's happening in fact i
think fewer merchants accept bitcoin now
than did a few years ago it was a
novelty in like 2017
i mean the novelty wore off because it
it doesn't work
and then they reinvented it as digital
gold they said okay you don't really
have to use it as a currency
it's just going to be digital gold well
it's nothing like gold it's got it
that's got nothing in common with gold
it's it's no more digital gold than if
you have a digital house
i mean you can't do anything with a
digital house that you could do with a
real house
you can't do anything uh with digital
gold that you could do with real gold so
this is just a pipe dream
and sure people have gotten rich could i
have made a lot of money personally
had i bought a bunch of bitcoin when i
first heard about it
and wrote it all the way up and sold it
today at 50 000 or any time
it sold it at 30 000 or 10 yeah of
course
but you know there are a lot of other
things that went way up that i didn't
buy
um there are some things that went way
up that i did buy so at least i didn't
miss out on every opportunity
um you know you got to pick your pitches
that you want to swing at
but you know i didn't swing at bitcoin i
guess you know but i still think that
most people
who are in bitcoin who are making fun of
me at the end of the day
i'm going to have the last laugh because
that you know it's like you're at a big
poker table
and you know you got a bunch of people
that don't know how to play poker but
for some reason they got lucky and they
got a bunch of chips
and they want to make fun of me you know
because i got a smaller stack
but if i know i'm a better player than
them i mean they can laugh all they want
knowing that at the end of the day i'm
going home with all their money you know
and they're just gonna bust out of the
game and so
i think a lot of these guys you know
laugh now you know go ahead
make all the you know fun of me all you
want i don't care
you know because i'm going to have the
last laugh and i'm going to have the
money
because i asked you something yeah i had
michael saylor on you guys have had your
battles uh
online i've had him on the podcast i
have invitations to the winklevis
uh and other people and and you know i
always like to do what's called
in the military my my friends and
relatives in the military tell me
is kind of this red team approach
because i think at the end of the day
you know people might not like you or
people might not like michael
but the bottom line is i care about my
listeners i care about my audience i
care about my students
and i'm i'm serious because what i want
to do is have this adversarial approach
and then
as scientists most of my audience are
scientifically friendly if not
necessarily scientists or engineers
but they can evaluate you know which
argument sounds better maybe hedging
bets i've had on jim simons one of the
most successful
uh people uh in hedge fund history uh
who's the
backer of the simon's observatory that i
co-run and this
um you know approach has worked well for
me i've asked you know
give me the strawman case for for gold
to
to uh to michael saylor and give me the
steel man approach and i want to ask you
do you see things in bitcoin uh first of
all
do you see a value in it besides a
perception good i agree with you it's
failed as a currency but by the way
there's millions of other
literally millions of other bitcoins
that you know could potentially be used
as currency but nobody's really saying
currency is
you know just because it has that in its
name that's what it's for i mean no one
ever envisioned it would be used for
smart
contracts and that's something i want to
get into later but the first question i
really want to ask you is a deeper
question again a philosophical question
when we have the overall thing is that
we're all trying to protect ourselves
our families our countries
against the perils of hyperinflation
collapse
destruction of wealth because
destruction of wealth is destruction of
work and i can't think of anything worse
than
destroying you know it's basically
enslavement of the human of the human uh
spirit
so i want to ask you don't you think
that eventually
if hyperinflation took over do you don't
you think another country
would be the sort of canary in the coal
mine uh not necessarily america in other
words we have so much
you know hegemonic control over the
world and and and even
uh beyond financial militarily etc we're
kind of
the country that people look to
philosophically so i want to ask you
would would there be another canary in
the coal mine that would alert us
hey we should have some hedge against
inflation just speaking
generally well you don't even need a
canary in the coal mine i mean
you need a hedge against inflation i
mean and you know a lot of things have
worked as hedges i mean people have
owned real estate people have owned
stocks i mean
people people own real things because
inflation erodes away the value of paper
claims
it doesn't erode away the value of real
wealth so the people who have to worry
about inflation are people who own bonds
uh people who have um you know cash
value in an insurance policy
people who have a fixed annuity people
living on fixed income from a pension
right that's where inflation really
gets you and then of course you know
wage earners because wages typically
lag other prices when there's inflation
and so
you know your your standard of living is
is is eroding away
and so you know we all need hedges
against inflation now
hyperinflation is a very rare
circumstance
which can completely wipe out your paper
claims
and i mean do i think people should have
a hedge against that well you don't have
to hedge against that specifically
because once you're hedged against
inflation well you're hedged against
hyperinflation too
right so it's just it's obviously it's
more important
to have the hedge the question is is
bitcoin
a hedge against hyperinflation
i don't think so i don't think it's a
hedge against any inflation i mean you
could say maybe it's a hedge
against stupidity i mean if people are
still stupid they'll maybe they'll buy
it
uh or greedy i mean i think it's the
combination of ignorance and greed that
really drives
the bitcoin price but the reason that
gold right and everybody wants to
compare gold to bitcoin
even though they're they're nothing in
common with that michael calls it
digital gold bars sitting in cyberspace
yeah yeah i mean look michael is a
professional bitcoin shill at this point
i mean he's all over the place i mean
that's why i came on your podcast
to kind of debunk some of the nonsense
that he was that he was selling on here
but
look he's trying to get people to buy
what he owns i mean obviously because
that's the only way to get bitcoin to go
up is if somebody else buys it
because you can't do anything with it
you can't use it for anything there's no
natural buyer but this gets me into why
is
gold a hedge against inflation well
when you own gold you own a commodity
you own a metal
right you own the most useful the most
valuable
metal in the periodic table right
now inflation makes all commodity prices
go up
right so if if there's a lot of
inflation wheat's going to go up
corn is going to go up oil's going to go
up right
now am i going to buy a bunch of wheat
am i going to buy a bunch of oil where
am i going to put it
right i mean it's very hard even if
those are the things i need
let's say i need to use a lot of oil i
don't let's say i don't use gold i'm not
a
jeweler i don't make jewelry i don't
make
you know semiconductors i don't actually
need gold maybe i don't even wear
jewelry
i need wheat right because i eat bread
or i need
oil because i i drive my car but i'm not
going to store the oil
because i mean what i'm where am i going
to put it but if i store the gold
right and gold goes up in price along
with oil along with wheat
i can take that gold and i can exchange
it either directly or indirectly
and then i can use that to buy my wheat
or my oil
because there is somebody out there that
needs that gold because they have to
make jewelry because that's their
business
or they need to conduct electricity or
they're making uh
crowns for dentistry or they're doing
something in aerospace or
whatever it is that needs gold right so
it's a it's a good
that can rise in value relative to other
goods that is easy for me to store
because i have to get out of paper right
oh my god
there's all this inflation i got to get
rid of my paper
how am i going to store my purchasing
power well over the centuries
gold has been a very convenient way to
store your purchasing power because it's
a real good
that's very you know it's you can get a
lot of value in a small space
every ounce of gold is the same as every
other ounce so it's you know it's easy
to use
as a medium exchange now people say well
why can't i use bitcoin for that
well bitcoin unlike gold
has no actual use so there is no
guarantee that anybody is going to want
your
your bitcoin in the future even though
they may want it now
to speculate on it you don't know and
there are historic relationships i can
take a look
at 100-year thousand-year charts if
they're around
gold versus wheat gold versus corn gold
versus copper
gold versus all sorts of things to have
some idea of a
relationship that you can expect over
time
there is no such relationship between
bitcoin and anything
i mean nobody knows oh you know what's
the proper price of
of this in bitcoin i mean there is none
there's nothing right of course michael
would push back as he did and i pushed
him on all the believe me
i never give anybody a free pass i'm
always a thank you gentlemen peter
i i want to reach conciliants but not
necessarily just to feel kumbaya let's
all get along
i want to just remind people on on
clubhouse we're talking on the youtube
channel if you want to see peter
and i having this conversation with a
beautiful blue shirt hearkening back to
his face yeah
pal my archer by the way yeah i am
getting over
not covid but i just you're normal no no
you're looking whatever
i said i know but i got a cough so yeah
i said i would kill anybody that came
out of covid with a six-pack
it looks like i'm i'm gonna have to come
after you peter you look very fit you
look like you've been converting to
physical wealth
as well as monetary health um i want to
ask you
when i asked him i said you know isaac
newton smartest guys in the world
i already said galileo died almost
penniless yeah
as you compared to irwin shift your
father who is a brilliant
uh person whose books are also very
valuable on the
on the gray market shall we say or you
can yeah you know before you do that go
to shiftbooks.com i sell some of his
books really cheap compared to what
they're
selling them on the you know ebay or
places like that i invested
in the kingdom of the malts back in the
malts
back in uh 2004 when i first started
listening to you it has gone up peter
a whopping 1 000 18 bucks but
thank you for so so i have that in my
california state retirement fund
but i said i said to uh to michael i
said look you know
just saying that something has uh has
interconvertibility
and so forth look at isaac newton he
invested in the south sea bubble
uh which was like a real estate ponzi
scheme he invested in other things
as i said he was very convinced that you
could turn uh base metals into gold and
thereby debasing it
and and michael replied well first of
all you know as warren buffett said
most of the gold ever mined all we seem
to do is dig it up
and then put it underground and then
have some guys with guns
sitting in front of it and whereas you
know he he's not a big bitcoin you know
hodler either
warren buffett but but the point is that
people pay
you know what they think something is
worth and my question to you is
isn't this of a different character i
remember you very presciently peter
in the late 90s uh first with the
dot-com bubble
and then in the early 2000s with the
real estate bubble
you were very prescient you called it
you were dead on peter schiff was right
i'll link to that video sometime in the
youtube description
however those bubbles as they were
lasted a mere two years
at maximum if you claim as you did in
2013 you
spencer retweeted today at a tweet from
you back in 2013 or something
uh it's it's cute to see you guys on on
twitter engaging and such fun
but anyway bitcoins about like 61 or 100
or whatever it was
and i just want to ask you how many
bubbles from your story
study as a historian of monetary um
knowledge as you are as a scholar what
bubble has lasted 13 years or more you
know at this point
and not well you know just gone up and
and survived bull and bear markets by
the way
well first of all the housing bubble
lasted a lot longer than that it really
got started in the mid
1990s along with the nasdaq bubble so
greenspan started inflating two bubbles
in
stocks and real estate in the 90s it's
just that when
the stock market buckle popped the air
kind of left that bubble
and went into the real estate bubble and
so it kind of kept going
up until 2005 you know 2000 it really
didn't blow up until 07 but it kind of
peaked in 2005.
so it really was about a 10-year bubble
uh with home prices going up much faster
than
they normally did so it it it's just
that it got really
crazy in those last few years right i
mean that's when it really went to the
to the main x-manic stage so if you want
to count the early years
of bitcoin when it was just like you
know people were gambling with their
lunch money it was just kind of uh
you know you had some libertarians you
know that had 100 bucks worth you know
people use what what how many did they
use to buy that pizza you know 100
you know whatever it was thousand or
more yeah yeah so when people were just
fooling around with you know
play money yeah i don't really count
that
yet bitcoin really came on the stage
when it ran up to a thousand right that
was what in 20
uh what was that 2014 or something like
that and and then it shot up all of a
sudden people
what the hell was this and and then you
know it spent the next few years kind of
going back down it went down to 2 300.
and then it really didn't start
catching real attention until 2017 when
all of a sudden it went up to 20 000. so
really that was the first year where all
of a sudden a lot of people
like looked at it and that's when people
started putting real money in it i mean
not just you know
play money right that they couldn't care
less if they lost right
um they they were starting to put real
money in people were like taking out
loans
using their credit cards taking out
mortgages and they started you know
buying bitcoin so really it started
in a big way in 2017. so it had 2017
2018 2019 2020 so you have four real
years
of this bubble where a lot of people are
putting a lot of money in it i mean real
serious money
uh so i don't you know is that a long
time
in the history of bubbles i mean
probably not i i don't know about every
bubble that's existed
over the course of time um but i think
this one is pretty unique i mean i got
to give it to
the the the big whales that have
orchestrated this thing it's a great
marketing campaign
and now they're even trying to sucker in
i mean they got michael saylor
and somehow they got um elon musk
to bite on it and of course i've been
saying look you know he's in a bubble
all on his own and so
maybe he doesn't want to throw pins at
bubbles in general and
he's maybe trying to you know tie his
bubble to the bitcoin bubble i don't
know but we'll see
uh how many more uh ceos
you know can be enticed into doing
something as crazy
is you know buying bitcoin on their
balance sheet i mean i was listening
this to uh
sailor i mean talking about you know we
have to hedge our cash
i mean you don't hedge something with
something riskier than what you're
hedging
i mean your hedge can't be i mean you
have to take something that has less
volatile
i mean if if you really are worried
about the dollar going down
uh you can certainly own swiss francs or
other currencies
uh if you think the dollar is going to
go down there's not nearly as much
volatility there
but if you think all fiat currencies are
going to go down and
you're really worried about inflation
well then you could put gold on your
balance sheet if that's what you're
worried about
but it makes no sense to buy bitcoin i
mean you might as well just buy back
your own stock
uh as by bitcoin i mean i mean or the i
think bitcoin is far riskier than any
corporation um so it just makes no sense
nobody who's worried about two or three
percent of your inflation
is gonna buy bitcoin that could collapse
you know two percent in in
five minutes i mean it can go down 20 30
50
you know easily you know in a week i
mean you can't buy that and say it's a
hedge i mean the whole thing is
ridiculous
so and i mentioned that to michael and
and he said um
well you know things things are
you know behave properly until all of a
sudden they don't and
and the the example that he gave is like
you know you're on a
you're on uh you know you're on a plane
and you know he's a pilot you know like
i am of small planes
and the plane is going down and and you
don't ask the you know the
the when they give you the oxygen mass
you don't say like oh does it have like
the proper ratio of nitrogen to carbon
dioxide in other words
like in a certain sense because it has
survived certain bare and bowl cycles
back in 2017 2018 and all the way down
last year and because it survived things
like uh threats of regulation
and so forth which by the way you point
out all the time that the us government
basically confiscated gold made it a
crime to have gold
and i asked him well what's to prevent
that from happening with bitcoin or just
like
my friend phil greenspun is in the
clubhouse as well actually invited me to
clubhouse
uh thank you phil it'll be on the stage
later but uh he said you know they
called it a windfall profits tax and
they do that now and other things too so
what's to prevent them for doing it from
gold if if it does go up again
or bitcoin and you know his response is
basically like well
you just have you know you can either
put the live mask life vest on or you
can't
and my my takeaway was well of course it
doesn't have a thousand year track
record
and then you know he would point out
well you know they used to use giant
blocks of stone as as currency as well
and a store is a value we don't do that
or grain
um so nowadays there are alternatives
that like uh my friend rockwell shot
told me about he's
also on clubhouse and he said like
there's contracts there's escrow there
are things that
blockchain can do and i think you know
the concern that i get from my audience
is that you conflate
all blockchain with bitcoin or vice
versa
so i mean would you dispute the fact
that things like ethereum and others
they have ability to act as like escrow
time valued contracts they
they can serve a purpose i mean can you
hand me escrow no you can't hand me an s
look i mean whether or not these
cryptocurrencies could serve some type
of purpose
doesn't necessarily equate to what
owning one of them
or a fraction of one of them may be
worth so i have no idea those are two
totally separate questions
but getting back to really what i think
you were trying to ask me
um i think that sailor's example
actually contradicts what he's trying to
say
because he says hey the plane is going
down and i'm handing you some oxygen are
you gonna start
arguing about whether that oxygen is you
know is pure enough or is it gonna work
right you're just gonna you know put it
on
well i think that argues for gold
because you know you know gold is going
to survive inflation hyperinflation it's
been doing that for
thousands of years you don't know that
with bitcoin
i mean to try to say bitcoin's been
tested and it survived
it hasn't been around long enough for
you to come back and say
yeah it's it's survived i mean i think
that bitcoin in the next recession if we
have a lot of inflation
i think a lot of people a lot of
millennials
are going to have to sell their bitcoin
i mean a lot of people have been holding
on their bitcoin
and they haven't sold it and this last
recession you know
maybe you know they would have uh had we
not had all this free money from the
government in fact a lot of that money
ended up going into crypto probably
but i think you have a lot of people who
have bitcoin and nothing else and
when times get rough and they need
money and all they got is bitcoin now
you start to see a lot of these holders
huddlers maybe reluctantly uh trying to
sell because they need money for
food they need money for rent if they're
still paying rent or they need money for
what energy or whatever it is uh and so
there's going to be a lot of people
selling
and there may not be people who want to
buy and that is the problem is that the
market could just evaporate
i mean you don't have any buyers uh
the price crashes i mean there is no
natural bitcoin buyer like there's a
natural buyer for most commodities or
a natural buyer for other assets uh that
have
income that you can ascribe a value to i
mean if a stock is overpriced
there may be a certain price where the
value investors will will see the value
as measured by its earnings and its
dividends and
they'll buy it if the price is right
same thing with real estate
but and commodities i mean if the
commodity price
is cheap enough i mean people will start
accumulating the inventory if they need
it i mean if gold got cheap enough
you know people who need gold would just
start building up in inventories they
use it for later i mean people just
buy it um and and so there's gonna be
changes but if all of a sudden
bitcoin is dropping and nobody now wants
to buy
it because it's falling and it doesn't
you know it looks like it's going to
keep dropping there is no
natural buyer so it seems like if in
that example
you want to play it safe you go with
gold
right if you're if you're a gambler i
mean because
bitcoin you're saying bitcoin has never
been used as a currency he's trying to
sailors saying well other currencies
have failed that's true
but bitcoin has never even succeeded so
i mean so how's it going to fail
i mean people say to me well peter you
can't use gold to buy a cup of coffee
because i said look you can't use
bitcoin
well you you don't use it today but gold
was a medium of exchange it was money it
was never a currency
currencies were backed by gold
currencies are money substitute
gold is the real thing gold functioned
as a currency as a money as a media of
exchange
for thousands of years just because
we're not using it now
doesn't mean it hasn't proven that it
can be used bitcoin has never been used
by any society
and so to say that it will one day is
nothing but pure speculation i don't
think people are saying that
anymore i think i agree with you peter
but i don't think people are saying that
they're saying it's no longer
it was it could be used potentially
theoretically i think you can get a
vending machine the guy bought a pizza
whatever
i agree 100 but they're saying it's a
store of value
okay but here's the thing so if it's
never going to be used as a currency
then what the hell value does it have
that you're storing see what
and when i'm storing my gold right when
i'm not using my gold when i'm
melting down my gold and i have it in a
bar i am storing
that metal because somebody in the
future
is going to need that metal i mean and
who knows i mean if we end up you know
you know with more technology we end up
you know with spaceships i mean who
knows the demand for gold
will probably be a lot greater in the
future we'll probably come up with all
kinds of applications for gold
uh and so when i have this bar of gold i
am storing
that metal gold never decays it doesn't
tarnish
the gold is going to be just as good in
a thousand years as it is today
and and so that's what i'm storing i'm
storing all the things
that people can do with gold right
because people keep telling me yeah gold
has no value gold which is such
pure nonsense but i mean i've never
heard so much nonsense except
so if i'm when i'm storing my gold right
i'm storing
the ability of somebody to use the gold
in the future even if it's never used as
money
as a mean of exchange i'm storing the
metal for the uses them
as a metal um what are you storing when
you stash away your bitcoins your
satoshis you got you know your satoshi's
on you know
whatever what exactly are you storing
for the future
right so i guess i want to ask you the
same question about um the gutenberg
bible
the last one that ever sold was sold in
uh like the mid 80s to like
i think sony corporation or fuji
corporation or something like a
corporation
it's now the biggest asset on the
balance sheets of this particular
company back when they thought you know
japan would eat the world for long
so what is the value of the gutenberg
bible it's got some paper
all right how many gutenberg bibles are
there
well there's uh there's only there are
pages and actually a page of the
gluten-free bible sells for a hundred
thousand dollars
under 40. under a hun so it's
it's a collector's item it's something
that's very rare
that not a lot of people have and so
when you have it you have something
unique
that a lot of other people may want to
possess that's the way humans are we
we like to have rare things in a way to
flaunt our wealth to kind of show people
show off how much money we have right i
mean this is actually
in a safe in the in this company's
basement that's never been right well 30
years
all right well they know because look
they know it's a rare item right it's a
real thing
that will have value and yes i mean
obviously
you know an expensive painting you know
is worth a lot more than the canvas and
the wood right if it's a rare
you know painting you know from you know
an artist who died you know four or five
hundred years ago even some of the ones
that are still alive
their paintings are very valuable but
even pokemon cards
right but if what you're arguing is that
bitcoin is going to be
value because collectors are going to
want to show off their bitcoin
no no there's 21 million of those things
they're never going to be it's a concern
it's a conserved quantity and in physics
conserved quantities have the property
of symmetry
under either time translation or other
properties and so he makes the point
that you can travel you can transfer it
at the speed of light so imagine what
it's nothing i mean yes if you got
nothing you could transfer it to speed
of light who cares
well you know for example there are
actually digital artworks that are
only available on the blockchain
actually computer-generated art that
sell for a good
amount of money and so there are things
like a bubble there too
well it could be but the point that he's
trying to make is imagine if you had
elon's ear
and you said elon buy this gold that's
better for you would how long would it
take to to
to take his treasury in dollars and
convert it to bricks of gold which we
then have to secure
and which then would be inflating at two
or three percent a year as mining
um costs uh as planning uh takes place
yeah that's another
ridiculous statement he made that
there's too much inflation
when it comes to gold i mean a two
percent increase
per year is fine i mean gold has been
money again for thousands of years
with that natural weight of inflation
and because of the growth in the
population
and because of the efficiencies that
come over time
as we develop more efficient ways to
produce things
even though the supply of gold increases
every year
it increases more slowly than the prov
the supply of stuff that we buy with
gold
so gold still gains its value despite
a relatively low uh rate of
of inflation that's relatively uh uh
uh you know dependable so i think for
when he was saying that oh this is
i can't have gold because there's too
much gold being mined i mean not that
it's all a bunch of nonsense but
but i wanted to get back on your
collector thing because
look if you if you think about
a bitcoin right what is a bitcoin it's
21 million satoshi's
or or 100 million satoshi's right so
there's 2.1 quadrillion satoshi's
so if all you're trying to do is have a
bitcoin in a collection you only just
need a satoshi
if the only reason you want a bitcoin is
to show it off in your wallet
hey look check out my my bitcoin you
know a satoshi is
that's all you need i mean there's so
many of these things they're never going
to be to the point where they're so
scarce that somebody is going to feel
special
because they own one and that even
assumes that
bitcoin is still valuable because the
only way bitcoin has any
even use is because all these miners are
out there
spending all this money keeping this
network going if the price of bitcoin
collapses
the miners are all gone so what good
what good is your bitcoin if you can't
do anything with it because there's no
way to transact it
because all the miners have stopped and
they don't want to waste all this money
creating electricity to validate your
transfer when the prices crash so i mean
and then you got i mean talk about you
know
trying to you know create make gold
artificially i mean
what's going to happen in 10 years let
alone 50 or 100 years
with quantum computing or i mean people
can look back at what we think is
you know top technology i mean maybe
maybe grammar school kids
uh you know in the future could could
hack a bitcoin
they look at it like what is this a joke
you know i i don't know i mean
we think that it's all cutting edge
technology
no i i mean but i mean but what do we
know i mean there's nothing though
yeah there's nothing about big
blockchain that couldn't have been
invented in the early 90s or whatever
even earlier before that it's
cryptography
and back then instead of 256 bits
you know uh hash and so so forth you use
56 bits or
64 bits or whatever so yeah it'd be a
little bit slower and we only had you
know 56k
modems back then but he makes the point
in the interview with me
that you know like this is not only it's
not it's not like another form of
pokemon card this is like for a digital
generation these are people that like
right now in the cache app on the swipe
app stripe app
you can do all sorts of transactions you
can buy you can change it into gold uh
gld at least
you could buy euro pacific you could buy
euro-pacific
funds with it um yeah you can you can
you can
you can convert it to dollars you have
to yeah but but you could do that with
anything
i mean long before there was bitcoin no
no well long before there was bitcoin
because i know i owned a broker dealer
right and we always we issued we gave
our clients if they wanted them debit
cards
right and the debit card
would uh be attached to their brokerage
account
so let's say you had a brokerage account
and all you had was common stocks and
you had notes
and you had no you had no um cash right
you just said common stocks
if you put the stocks in a margin
account right
you could just take that debit card and
and just start
buying stuff and it's like well i'm
using my ibm to buy a pair of socks
well technically no because the guy
that's selling you the socks is getting
dollars
what we're doing is i'm giving you a
loan against your
ibm and if you don't pay it back we sell
the ibm to get you know because we
advance the dollars
but that's all that's happening with
bitcoin people are able to use bitcoin
if they own it there are all kinds of
convenient ways why
where you can sell it quickly to get
dollars
or euros or some other currency and then
you're using that other currency
to buy the things that you want you know
because outside of a handful of people
who may want your bitcoin and in that
case it's more like a barter transaction
where
hey you you know you you want to buy
this from me
i want bitcoin because i'm i'm a hodler
so i'll barter you
the bitcoin i mean people aren't using
it you know as money where they're just
taking it and then spending it
if you just want the bitcoin because you
want to own it
it's really barter you're going
backwards to barter economy
where bitcoin is like another good that
you would barter
it's not an intermediary because the
person actually wants
the bitcoin you know when when you buy
something from somebody with dollars
that guy doesn't want your dollars he
wants what he can buy with the dollar
sure same
well it depends if it's well but if it's
a jeweler
he does he needs the gold right but um
if somebody just says hey i want bitcoin
and i'll take it in exchange for some
product that's barter
right bitcoin is the end so it's not
acting as money it's acting as a good
that you're exchanging but nobody is
using
bitcoin as money and it's you know it's
way too expensive to use it as money now
i mean if you want to buy something like
if
if elon musk actually started selling
tesla's
and accepting bitcoin which he went yeah
and
well assuming it actually ever happens
yes you could buy a 50 000 car
economically with bitcoin
as a payer although i don't know what
they do i mean you know how quickly just
the price changes very quickly
so you know i it would be very hard i
mean obviously you can't price the tesla
in bitcoin
you have to price it in dollars and
allow somebody to pay
in bitcoin based on the exchange rate at
that moment in time
um but assuming he could do that okay
but if you want to buy a sandwich with
bitcoin
the cost of buying the sandwich today is
too expensive
but if people actually started to use
bitcoin on a much larger scale the cost
of those transactions would skyrocket
i mean it's the most inefficient thing
to use as a medium exchange which is why
so many people say well we're not going
to use it as a mean of exchange
we're just going to use it as a store of
value which gets back to my question
that you really couldn't answer
if bitcoin isn't a digital currency then
what the hell are you storing
when you own it and you can't tell me
that you're
it's a collectible and that you're
creating a valuable collection
that people are going to like oh my god
you got a you've got a brand you've got
a bitcoin from
your from 2021 bitcoin my wow that's
beautiful i mean that's never going to
happen
no of course not but i think that that
point is that there's this proof-of-work
argument that in order to have it uh in
order to mine a coin or transfer or
attack or
undermine literally undermining a
bitcoin
you must put in a certain amount of
computational energy which takes
yes and i i get that because they're
trying to compare that to gold because
obviously gold just can't be created it
needs to be mined
and it takes a lot of work to mine gold
and so all the value of that work
is in that coin but
that the idea that work in and of itself
means value is a flawed concept i mean
i mean there are some keynesians that
believe in this for these government job
programs
but the reason that gold has value
is not because a lot of labor was
required
to mine it out of the ground it's
because
after you've expanded all that labor and
all that other resources
you now have a medal that can be used
for something
it's like if i hired people to
dig ditches right these are government
type jobs and then i hired other people
to fill the ditches back
up right and they spend all day digging
ditches and filling them back up
there's a lot of work involved but have
they created any value
no they've created nothing i don't have
anything at the end of the day that i
didn't have at the beginning of the day
right so all that work was done and
maybe they can prove that they did the
work maybe they have photographs
of the big ditch that they dug before
they filled it back up with dirt
and they can prove to me that they did
all this work
fine but they created no value that is
the problem with bitcoin yes
it requires a lot of work to make one
and unfortunately
that's a lot of waste we're wasting all
kinds of resources
a lot of energy is being squandered to
produce
nothing you know there's no value there
yes
somebody is buying it but if we didn't
use all that energy to produce a bitcoin
we could have used that energy to do
something else and so
what you have to look at is what is
society giving up
because we decided to make all these
bitcoin right
what could we have had that we don't
have and what other goods are more
expensive
because the energy to create them was
more expensive because we wasted so much
of it
on bitcoin now i know to the people who
own the bitcoin and bought them a lot
cheaper and who are able to sell they
don't think it's a waste from their
perspective
just like the people who i paid to dig
ditches and fill them back up again
from their perspective these jobs
weren't a waste because they got a
paycheck
but from society's perspective and the
taxpayers who foot the bill it's a
complete waste because we got
nothing as a result of the work and at
the end of the day we're getting nothing
from all this energy and labor we're
wasting
making these bitcoins so i think
you know what he's saying is that you
know this this has a special appeal and
maybe you'd say it's an
maybe you'd say it's a you know it's a
greater uh delusion a massive delusion
and
by the way i do want to take questions
from the audience on clubhouse
and on my youtube channel dr brian
keating so please go
there start taking some questions in
just a bit i'll start with my friend
rockwell who
if anybody are joining in my clubhouse
room yeah please yeah
you've gone up uh 400 300 subscribers
200 subscribers oh really i'm getting
more subscribers
yeah you're you're you're reflecting the
brian keating glow it's called the
bitcoin bump uh so you'll soon have more
yeah i do i do have more
well maybe maybe you're getting a few of
mine maybe your subscribers have gone up
too
no 69 scratching each other's backs
that's right yeah
so i'll take a question from my friend
rockwell uh who is one of the moderators
in just a second i want to
refer people to go to the uh brian
keating
dr brian keating youtube channel and go
to peter's channel subscribe to his
channel
find them on twitter find them on
instagram i love the instagram updates
that you give every so often peter
thanks for signing up for that
that's been really really fun for me to
follow along with you're kind of an
inspiration you have a huge youtube
following
i see black in the back made undoubtedly
of gold
uh in the back i don't think there's any
gold well there's a silver color i doubt
there's any silver in there
but i don't get another plaque until i
have a million subs i got that one
for a hundred thousand yeah years ago
the next one is a million and i you know
i haven't even hit i'm gonna hit half a
million this year at some point i'm
pretty close so
yeah i'm sure you know but then i gotta
double it from there to get to a million
so that that ain't easy
well that's the uh you know power log
growth the first the first digit is the
hardest to move and it goes all downhill
from there
so i want to take a uh i want to take a
question first from i
i cannot not take philip greenspun
because he got me on clubhouse
philip has something to say i'm inviting
him up on stage phillip then rockwell
and then there's a whole bunch of people
uh in the audience
some questions from uh from there so
peter you keep your phone
off and then i will yeah i'm pretty sure
like you're going on the phone okay go
ahead fill up
a greenspun go ahead oh no i can hear
something how do i
stop that my volume must have come up
yeah hold on one second phil peter can
you hear me
yeah but i'm also hearing it on my phone
i can't get the volume to go down why
not
oh just yeah just turn crank the volume
way down no i'm i'm pushing the volume
button but the things
oh all right maybe it is down okay go
ahead okay yeah
phil go ahead now okay two questions i
still hear it um
first of all could bitcoin get a lift
from wealth taxes let's say president
harris
puts in a three percent annual wealth
tax um
and people want to uh you know quietly
move money out of the u.s
um or you know from another country with
the wealth tax
uh so could that be the enduring value
of bitcoin as a way of moving money
away from wealth taxation and secondly
uh what did you think about the uh
crypto anonymous guys
uh posting you know the bit short inside
kryptos doomsday machine in which he uh
said that uh fraud at tether limited
was uh the main source of uh the high
value of the
bitcoin right now so those are my two
questions can it have value from
people moving money overseas
the first question at least with respect
to the us
is it's a a tax on your global wealth
so if you move your bitcoins abroad yet
you still own them
uh then you're still gonna have to pay
the tax and i think that
you know bitcoin is not that anonymous i
mean that in fact the bitcoiners in
order to
uh you know get wall street on board in
order to get the bigger money the
pensions the hedge funds on board
they really have to concede oh no it's
not it's not for drug dealers and money
launderers oh no it's
it's easy to trace i mean you know
nobody would want to use bitcoin
to hide things because you know there's
such a big digital footprint here
and i do think that more regulation is
going to come on
uh to bitcoin i mean no question about
it i mean just you know
this is what government does they
regulate stuff and you know i'm in the
banking industry in brokerage and i see
all the
crazy regulations and i know even more
of them are coming down the pipe
uh for bitcoin that is going to make it
even more expensive to transact in it
than it already is
but if anything you know if there is a
wealth tax
then people who have bitcoin might have
to sell some of their bitcoin
to pay their tax on their bitcoin and so
it could easily be a catalyst
for some of the uh huddlers the big
whales that have never sold any bitcoin
they might have to start selling because
remember
you have to market to market every year
and then pay a tax on what the paper
value is
and so what would happen if a lot of
this bitcoin that has never
you know been for sale all of a sudden
it has to be sold i mean the same thing
would happen to people who own big
concentrations like elon musk
they start taxing him on his tesla well
he has to start selling a bunch of tesla
to get the money to pay that tax
and so you know a lot of things could
come up for sale
so i don't think that bitcoin is
a hedge for that look bitcoin is going
to go up as long as more people are
buying it
and and i think what attracts people to
it now especially some of the bigger
people
is hey if i have if i'm a big person
with a lot of influence
if i buy my bitcoin and then tell
everybody i bought it
after the fact and then come up with all
kinds of pie in the sky
promises about what i might do in the
future i can immediately
make my own purchase you know
on paper being a profit because i can
i can i don't even have to dump it i can
pump it and hold it
because if i'm just judged by the
unrealized paper game
which a lot of times you want to credit
that oh look you know look at how much
i have look if everybody that owns
bitcoin if every single person that
owned it agreed not to sell it no matter
what the price was
bitcoin can go to a million right but
would it it would it mean anything
if you had a million dollars worth of
bitcoin that you never could use for
anything that you could never sell
no what difference it's all a delusion
because then one guy decides hey i want
to sell one is
satoshi and the whole market crashes
right
so but it's easy with this type of
market
to just buy it and then tell everybody
you own it
and then get the price to go up and now
you look like some kind of genius you
got all this profit but you know what
so far and i haven't seen the market
today last i checked before we did this
tesla was down almost another two
percent which means that even though
bitcoin
had gone from like 35 000 to 50 000
since tesla
announced they bought it elon musk
announced they bought it for tesla
tesla stock had dropped about seven
percent
while the market was hitting new highs
so so far
tesla's shareholders have not been
rewarded by this decision
yeah even though the bitcoin on paper
have gone up but
the key is you know what would happen if
musk
tried to sell that uh bitcoin now of
course he would never say in advance i'm
gonna get rid of my bitcoin he's not
that dumb
he's gonna sell all his bitcoin before
he lets anybody know but
somebody would have to buy that bitcoin
that might be a big order
i mean it's one thing to buy one and a
half billion dollars worth of bitcoin
uh but i think it's a whole other story
to try to get rid of it
okay thank you very much phil for that
question uh we have a bunch
oh i didn't get to his second question
oh yeah get to the second question sorry
yeah go ahead peter
yeah as far as tether is concerned look
i don't know i mean
i mean i've always been suspicious that
you know tether
was not 100 backed by dollars that they
were doing some fractional reserve
i mean that they were issuing more
tethers than they had actual dollars and
then later on i think they came out and
admitted yeah
you know it's 70 or 80 i forget the
ratio that they say they have
uh but i even doubt that i mean do they
really have 30 billion dollars in a bank
somewhere
uh behind you know because if you look
at the supply of tethers i mean they're
they're really up there i mean is i
wouldn't want to keep all that money in
tether
i mean because i i mean
but people have it the whole thing seems
too risky because
what is the upside of tether it's never
going to be worth more than a dollar
right what is the downside it crashes
because they're
they're counterfeit so it's like i
wouldn't want to keep much money in
tether
given the huge downside and the limited
upside
and if a lot of people actually sold
their bitcoin and all they got is tether
they might have got nothing they might
be holding on to a dream
so i don't know you know the guy that
created it you know lives
you know a few houses down from me you
know brock pierce i think he's the one
that's
got it started but um i mean i've never
really had a discussion with him about
it
um and i don't think he's involved in it
anymore so i don't know that he knows
what's going on
but you know i think tether is part of
it my guess is that they did
you know inflate the tether supply
strategically when bitcoin starts
selling off
they start printing tethers and buying
them and
and so it's almost like a central bank
intervening in the market and just like
because
because if they issue tethers the
company tether what is it what's a
company called that issues them
tether you know i don't know but they
could just print them up
right i don't know who's auditing them
have they really been
honest audits but yeah i i mean i think
that that is
part of the problem i'm sure you know
where there's smoke there's fire there's
probably truths i know they're being
investigated
so but you know obviously just because
they're being investigated doesn't mean
that there's
there's anything there uh but we'll see
but my my
guess knowing you know what's going on
with the whole crypto industry
and all of the the shilling and all the
pump and dump that i see
anyway and again so many things that
people in
bitcoin community say so much stuff is
so completely absurd
you know they have to tell so many lies
in order to pump bitcoin
when you're lying and you're not being
honest then you know you have to call
into question
everything that's being done you know i
mean i don't tell
lies when i'm trying to tell people why
i think they should
invest a certain way you know why they
should maybe buy gold or silver or
foreign stocks i'm not lying to them to
get them i'm i'm telling them honest
opinions
but i see so many people out there that
i know are telling bold-faced lies
uh about not just about bitcoin but
about gold or all sorts of things
in order to get people to buy bitcoin
great thank you peter we have a question
now from my friend rockwell
shaw who is uh one of my uh
leading indicators he tells me and
informs me about all sorts of things
going on in the world of blockchain i've
learned a lot from
rockwell are you there ready to ask
peter chef a question or comment
oh absolutely peter thank you so much
for joining us
i believe you're a very smart person and
so please don't
uh take my question the wrong way i can
hear
the collective screams of all the
bitcoin bulls in the audience wishing
that they could say something
every time they hear a logical
fallacy or something that's not quite a
bit correct so for example
in the discussion we talk about how you
can't buy anything with bitcoin
but in fact you can buy many things with
bitcoin right you can google
how what can you buy with bitcoin you'll
see tons and tons of lists you can go to
overstock.com you can buy many things
with the clock
yeah okay let i'll stop you right there
because look a lot of people
a lot of people think that i'm you know
lying or being a hypocrite because they
say hey
you can buy gold at shift gold with
bitcoin
and you can't what you can do
right and this is part of the marketing
and most of the things that you can buy
with bitcoin
this is how it works right because we
signed up with a company called bitpay
back in uh 2014 we first signed up
mid-2014
and what that enabled us to do was put
something on our website that was like
bitcoin accepted right
but what happens is when somebody has
bitcoin
and they want to buy something from
shift gold
bitpay acts as an intermediary and what
happens is
the bitcoins goes from the customer of
shift gold to bitpay
bitpay turns around and sells those
bitcoin into the market
gets dollars and then pays those dollars
to shift gold
and then shift gold uh sends the the uh
the gold to the customer so
you're not buying anything with bitcoin
you are selling your bitcoin
in order to get dollars to then buy
something well you can do that with any
asset you can sell any asset
to get money to buy another asset uh so
that that that is the the the the
fallacy of it my point was
you can't take your bitcoin and and go
to shift gold and say hey
peter i i got i want to buy an ounce of
gold
uh how much is it in bitcoin and i'm
going to send you the bitcoin
and and that'll cover the transaction we
don't do that we can't do that we only
mark up our gold like one or two percent
there would be no way for me to be able
to to do a transaction by the time i
actually got the bitcoin it could be
worth less than the gold i sold you
uh and so it it we can't we can't do
business at bitcoin it's it's impossible
all right here's uh he has a follow-up
yeah go ahead rockwell hold on go ahead
totally fair
so part of your thesis is that you
should only invest in things that have
intrinsic value
right that bitcoin doesn't have any
intrinsic value and so my question to
you
is this as you point the goal you know
if i bought gold in 1935
the the per ounce going rate was a
little bit above 500
in 2018 inflation-adjusted dollars if i
then sold that same gold
in 2003 70 years later
i would have roughly lost
about 150 per ounce so i would have held
on to an asset
for 70 years and actually lost money
with them
well yeah but the problem with with your
time
period is you're picking a a
a peak and a trough over an extended
period of time
and you're assuming you're assuming that
no gold was purchased
during that 70-year period that like you
bought all of your gold because if you
go to
you know where where the price of gold
was at a certain point
um you know and then you measure it and
you're picking you're picking points if
you bought gold let's say
in 1930
or 1920 or 1930
and you held that goal today
and you just looked at it today you know
i think it's actually
beaten the dow jones but if you count
dividends
it hasn't and that would be expected
because
the the stocks stocks are a productive
asset
gold is just a commodity but what you
compare gold to
is paper dollars so if i had an ounce of
gold
you know in 1920 or 1930 whatever year
you're picking
and and i and i put that in the ground
and somebody else took
paper dollars and put those in the
ground who preserved their value better
the person who has gold
or the person who has paper obviously
the person who has gold i mean gold was
20
an ounce in 1920. it's almost two
thousand dollars an ounce
uh now so if i took a twenty dollar bill
and buried it in the ground
you know a hundred years ago you know i
still have twenty dollars what can i buy
but if i
buried an ounce of gold in the ground a
hundred years ago i have
an ounce of gold which is now two
thousand dollars it's a hundred times
the paper one right so i think it's
dangerous yeah yeah so go ahead rockwell
funny enough if i bury my private key
with bitcoin
10 years ago it would be worth far more
than what gold is today but that's not
my favorite yes but
yeah and and and 10 years from now it
may be worth nothing
okay peter hold on he's he hasn't he's
he's winding up he's
she's yeah but look at the volatility i
could have bought bitcoin at twenty
thousand
and then it went to three thousand what
if i bought it at twenty thousand and
seven yeah
so we shouldn't cherry pick up rock well
just ask one yeah
and then peter will answer one question
go ahead yeah perfect
so peter since 2003 the price of gold
has 6x and my question to you is this
what percentage of the price of gold
today is intrinsic value
versus speculation are you telling me
that since 2003
gold has become 6x more useful
6x more used what percentage would you
ascribe
is the intrinsic value of the 800 1800
well all right well first of all in 2003
gold was just coming off of a 20-year
bear market so i would argue that in
2003
the price of gold was cheap it was very
undervalued
and so it really shouldn't have been
that low to begin with
but number two you can look at the
current cost of mining gold
and the price of gold today is not that
much higher than the cost
of mining it so there isn't some
enormous amount of profit to be earned
by mining gold so if gold were really
overvalued there would be this huge
incentive for people to try to explore
for it and mine it because there'd be
this big
profit and that's not the case i mean
gold
you know really uh doesn't reflect much
of a premium for the big mining
companies i mean it's better now than it
was a few years ago
but i think if you look at the money
supply that existed
back then of dollars and the money
supply that exists today
and not only the money supply that
exists today
but the potential future money supply
given the trajectory of our deficits and
the course that we're on
i would actually argue that i think gold
may be even more undervalued at 2
000 than it was at 300 or 400 given the
circumstances that exist today
because what gold is really measuring is
the value of the dollar i mean how many
dollars do you need to buy an ounce of
gold and and not just how many that you
need today
but how many might you need in the
future and so people are voting to store
their future purchasing power in gold
rather than storing it in dollars
um but you know the idea that the only
value of gold
comes from speculators is nonsense that
that's not where the value comes from
i mean speculators are speculating on
what the future value of gold would be
based on the people who need it and what
they're going to be willing to pay
if there was no actual use for gold
right if gold was like bitcoin
if you couldn't make a watch out of gold
right if you couldn't do anything with
gold if you couldn't conduct electricity
with gold if it had
actual absolutely no use then you could
argue that its value comes purely from
speculation
but when that's not the case when you're
talking about the single most valuable
metal on the periodic table
a metal that could do things that no
other metal can do and it and
and therefore you know people need it
for certain applications
it has value you know and i i think it
it
it's cheap at the current price you know
so
next up definitely brian let me make my
best all right
i don't think about time go ahead he
wants to make a bet peter
yeah i don't like to make bets on
bitcoin because you know anything can
anything's possible
you don't want to make a bad rock sorry
if you're going to bet on the price of
bitcoin going up i can see that the
price of bitcoin might go up
yeah i just you know i just don't want
to own any that's my bet
people keep saying why don't you bet me
this look i have a big bet on bitcoin
i own none of it right people say well
just buy a little bit of the hedge i
i'm it's not a hedge i don't care i'm so
confident it's going to be worthless
that it's i don't even want to have one
percent of my net worth in it i don't
want to waste one percent of my net
worth on bitcoin
i i i'll i'll gamble on something else
yeah you're uh you're
you're a toddler you're a throw out for
dear life
[Laughter]
uh when i think about you and i think
about the things that you've called
first of all i see you as a i want to
talk again philosophical let's get off
bitcoin for a little bit
and then we'll take some more questions
on uh on clubhouse by the way
we're trying to get them over a thousand
followers on this app so that he'll come
back and uh maybe we'll do another part
two
but um but you know thinking about when
you have these
um risks in in life and i want to know
because you're a businessman you own
uh and and founded you know things
really i i feel that you
are a self-made man your dad obviously
cast a huge shadow on your life
i'm self-made in terms of money my dad
didn't give me any money he gave me
knowledge
so so that helped obviously a lot of
mental capital but he didn't
he he died penniless so i didn't inherit
anything from him
right and he didn't give me any money
during life i mean he gave me a little
bit you know he paid for college you
know he helped me with that
and he helped raise me yeah yeah so he
raised me it's not like he abandoned me
he was a father he helped support me
but you know once i went out on my own
and i got my first job
i you know i never i never went home for
any money i mean whatever money i had i
earned
right i want to ask you you know when
you look at his life and
and obviously he cast this this big
influence on you
and and fathers play this role mothers
play this role uh later in
uh if you'll spare a few more minutes uh
coming up i ask you the questions i ask
all my guests when they come on the into
the impossible podcast but
a lot of them are about legacy and
before i ask you about your legacy what
you want to bequeath
to you know the future biological and
ideological
errors that you will certainly uh
possess i want to ask you
if you resent your dad uh i'm sorry to
ask it in that way but
but he could have had this life where he
was with you with your
grant with his grandchildren uh which
you have a few
and uh and your brother um who's who's
another
uh amazing individual i'm gonna ask you
do you do you ever resent the fact that
he took this stance
and maybe just recapitulate really
quickly his principles
what he did why he was thrown in jail
and how he was
basically taught you know i mean it's
not so much that i resent it
i mean i feel bad about it um i feel
even you know more bad for him on a lot
of the things that he missed out on
you know while he was fighting this
fight against the government
um but he was a man of of deep
conviction
and he fought for the things that he
believed in
to the exclusion of a lot of other
things that a lot of other people may
have
placed as a priority i mean his own
personal comfort his own
family i mean my father worked very very
hard i mean he spent
you know every day he worked weekends he
never took a vacation
and even though he didn't pay taxes i
mean he i mean he didn't do anything i
mean he didn't
real i mean he took a few vacations and
but he drove an old
car you know he lived in an apartment he
never had any of the trappings of of
wealth or anything
um and that wasn't you know what he was
trying to do he was fighting for a cause
and and so you know i mean he did what
he wanted to do he touched a lot of
people
he influenced a lot of people a lot of
people today you know
email me about my father i meet them and
they tell me how
he influenced them so i think he built a
legacy
i mean my children uh don't really know
him
i mean um but they will be able to get
to know him from his books
he he does have you know i still
maintain his website paynoincomtax.com
uh there's a lot of uh his uh radio show
they did
he did a um uh online radio show
so i mean he can still speak to my
children
that way and so my children can get to
hear him i mean maybe
his personality doesn't come out as much
he was great with kids and
he was a you know did magic and he was a
great he played the guitar and he sang
and he danced i mean he had you know he
was a great guy
uh but you know he got his life got
consumed
like you know like ahab you know in a
whale you know he just you know was
on this uh how do you reason because you
know in some sense uh
i think we're all you know our parents
children how do you resist that
temptation either
you know what do you do to avoid the
pitfalls
that your father got on i mean well look
i mean i saw how my father lived his
life
and that wasn't the life that i wanted
to live uh you know i wanted
i wanted you know a lot of stuff that my
dad didn't have
not just material stuff but i wanted to
have more time for personal things
and and so but i still wanted to
you know carry the torch in the message
of limited government and the
constitution and sound money so
i took a lot of the economics that i
learned from my dad
and i and i and i brought that to a
greater audience than he did
you know a lot more people you know know
me than knew my dad um
and so i've you know achieved a degree
of notoriety that
that exceeds what he had um but
you know i didn't pay the price
personally
i mean i'm i'm paying my taxes although
now i'm not paying that much because i
live in puerto rico
so um you know and so this is you know
i'm playing within the irs
rules instead of trying to you know play
by the constitution and force the
government
to obey the law you know by the way i
you know i said i didn't get anything
from my dad look this this ring here was
my dad's
and he wore this ring all the time he
had another one which i don't know what
happened to but i have this ring
and it's made of gold so that's you know
you can't you know you can't give your
kids
a a bitcoin ring but you know i almost
lost this ring
i was swimming in the beach out front of
my house my condo
and i went into actually i was on the
sand and i took my
my seven-year-old and i he was doing
something with my five-year-old
he was throwing sand at her so i picked
him up and i walked i threw him
into the ocean and when i threw him i
had been swimming and my ring just went
flying off my finger i guess
and it went to the bottom of the ocean
and i was like [ __ ] i spent like a
couple hours with some friends we're
trying to find it we're sifting around
the sand and i can't find it
so i was like i thought i lost the ring
but then i i
i put something on this facebook page uh
an act 2022 group
and someone said hey call up the ring
finders there's a couple of them in
puerto rico so there's a website ring
finders
so i found this guy in san juan and i
told him where i lost the ring i was so
no problem i'll find it
and he came with an underwater metal
detector went into the ocean and within
five minutes he found the ring
buried under the sand in the ocean yeah
i had that experience
so it was there for a day but i got it
back but yeah but i have a few other
things
i have some artwork that was my dad's i
have some other
possessions that he had that remind me
of my dad that you know i'm glad that i
have them
how do you manage your time you speak at
all these things before covet and even
now with your podcast
shift report shift radio uh you have all
your businesses
how do you do because i suffer from that
peter i have not
a master level of wealth or success but
with my kids and my wife
you know i think like every time i say
yes to do something
i'm telling a two-year-old no i'm not
gonna be there for whatever so how do
you you've got young kids you've got
grown kids
and you have a wife how do you balance
your time and do all the things you do
um and and know what to say no to
because you must say no a lot although
you didn't say no to this maybe you
should have in retrospect
yeah well my grown kid is only 18 so he
still has a lot of growing obviously a
lot of mental growing since he's
into bitcoin um
but and you know and again the primary
motivation i you know they said oh this
guy had sailor on so i watched your
sailor interview and i was like god this
guy's off the deep end
and it's not that he's not an
intelligent guy i mean i'm sure sailor
has a higher iq than i do i mean the
guy's
he's not i'm not saying he's a dummy he
obviously can't be
but he's got some kind of screw loose or
it's all bs
i mean that's so see i never know when i
hear somebody talking like this about
bitcoin
i don't know they should people should
have to be hooked up to lie detectors
when they're talking about bitcoin
because i have no problem i mean i i'll
you know i'll do a debate with some
bitcoin guy and i'll have a lie detector
on
and i mean i'm completely honest but you
get somebody a bitcoin guy because
everybody says oh peter you know he's
not objective right because he sells
gold i mean first of all
gold is a small part of my business and
i can't move the price of gold no matter
what i say
gold market is so big and so liquid i
cannot
move the price of gold if i said hey i
put all of my net worth into gold
i'm gonna put every dollar i have into
gold every every day i mean it's not
gonna change the price of gold
right but they give these bitcoin guys a
complete pass
when they have an entire business built
around bitcoin
they have all their life savings in
bitcoin and then they come on there and
talk about how great bitcoin is and how
everybody should buy it it's going to
the moon
and nobody questions their objectivity
you know
when they used to let me on cnbc which i
haven't been on for years and at this
point i wouldn't even go on if they
invited me
but when they were inviting me on
whenever i came on and talked about gold
somebody always say oh [ __ ] you're
just saying that you're just trying to
sell gold
you you know you're just you know
talking they always accused me
of of of having a bias which i didn't
i i tell i encourage people to buy gold
because i think they should and by the
way i'm not selling my own gold
i'm not selling any of my gold i'm
talking about right you're hundreds of
intermediate
but i see on cnbc every single day
all throughout the day one guest after
another
touting bitcoin because they're from the
bitcoin industry
right and their whole life is based on
bitcoin going up
and they they spew all kinds of nonsense
and not once have i ever heard
anybody say oh come on i mean are you
just saying i mean you come on you're so
biased
i mean what else are you gonna say you
know no one ever does that
and in fact the other thing that's funny
is when i used to come on cnbc
and talk about inflation or potential
hyperinflation
or you know the dollar being debased or
the federal reserve but i had all that
stuff i was saying
and then i would say oh you should buy
gold oh that's crazy that's nonsense
that's never going to happen
yet everybody that goes on to tout
bitcoin they can say all the stuff that
i used to say
and they never get any flack it's all
okay yeah that's great yeah that sounds
reasonable
so if you think people should buy gold
you're not
able to go on cnbc and tell people
why because they'll make fun of you but
as long as you're touting bitcoin you
can say whatever you want
and nobody is going to question you know
at the same time because everyone on
cnbc they're all bullish on the stock
market they love the fed
they love fiat money but they also love
bitcoin
they want everybody they want everyone
in their audience you know it's funny
and then i see grayscale their biggest
advertiser
advertising and i think okay well that
makes sense now i mean obviously they
want that ad money to keep on flowing
and so how does how does grayscale get
the money to buy all these ads from all
the people dumb enough to buy into the
trust
so they they don't want anybody to come
on and say oh maybe bitcoins you know
maybe it's going to crash maybe these
guys are
not being honest so that's where you
have all the bias
the bias is not me i'm not biased
against bitcoin
it's all these other people that their
entire life depend on bitcoin who are
biased in favor of it i'm just being
objective
but peter you know what they say that
you know richard feynman greatest
physicist some say of the 20th century
said
the first principle is you must not fool
yourself
and the second principle is you're the
easiest person to fool in other words we
all have confirmation bias we all have
some cost
fallacy that we're because we're human
beings even scientists you know oh
you're a scientist
let's listen to the sign to no i'm like
don't listen to me because
a scientist peter is the least likely
person to trust other scientists that's
what our job is is to not trust you
and to not listen to experts as richard
feynman said uh
you know science is the belief in the
ignorance of experts i want to ask you
um you know thinking back whenever i see
bitcoin the funniest thing to me is that
they always show it as a gold coin
it kind of like undermines itself that's
part of the fraud
i mean that's why you mine bitcoins
right you don't actually mine them you
solve a mathematical problem right how
is that mining
yeah but they wanted to make believe
that this is alchemy this is the fraud
that's why i call it fool's gold
is because they're representing it as if
it were gold
and yes bitcoin replicated a lot of the
properties
that gold has that made it a better form
of money
than cattle or salt or you know or
or or wheat or anything else you know
whatever could have been used as money
and so bitcoin replicated those
qualities but it doesn't represent
the actual underlying value of gold
without which none of the other
properties would have mattered
dividing nothing doesn't matter right
the fact that
uh you know it's fungible or immutable
wherever these things are
ultimately doesn't matter if if you
don't have anything
it matters to gold because you have a
you have real gold you have a valuable
shuttle so you know so the whole thing
is a fraud but if you're talking about
confirmation bias
yeah it's all on the bitcoiners because
their confirmation bias is the price
i'm wrong because the price went up even
though i never said
that the price couldn't go up i just
said that it won't stay up now
yes i did not realize it would go up
this much
from the beginning and maybe a lot of
people who did buy it originally
didn't think it would go this high maybe
some of them did
but obviously a lot of people bought
bitcoin and sold it when at 200
or a thousand you know and they don't
have it they thought that was high and
they got out so i don't know
so and i don't know where i would have
gotten out had i bought it right i mean
who knows i mean would i still own it if
i got it
but you know yes i didn't gamble
on bitcoin and i could have right and
if if i had put all of my net worth into
bitcoin
and i held it all until today would i be
richer
yes of course but how many people did
put all their net worth i mean how
i mean if i had just put you know one
percent
and i did it you know when it was a
thousand
or five it would really it wouldn't even
make a difference really to me i mean
obviously if i put one percent of my net
worth when it was a penny yeah it'd make
a big difference but
you know if i'd had done it back then i
mean it's not i mean and i've i've
bought other things i've bought other
investments over the last five years
that had 10x or 20. so i but again i
didn't have my whole net worth in them
because i diversified
right you know and so yeah is there
somebody that just bet at all on bitcoin
they took a hell of a lot of risk doing
that right
yeah about the about getting back to the
scientific hypothesis so
there's a question of what is science
like just because somebody practices the
scientific method
even the great isaac newton the greatest
physicist in history
uh you know some say you know he was
prone to these confirmation biases to
this
this belief that astrology had something
to teach people
uh that you could do alchemy that you
could convert base metals into gold but
now in the 20th century carl popper
famous philosopher of science
came up with what he called the
demarcation hypothesis or
or or way of ascertaining or assaying
literally
what uh what constituted science not
whether or not it's right
but whether or not something is a
scientific subject or if it's
metaphysics or beyond derision so he
came up with this
criteria you probably know it it's
called falsification
so he said that like things that cannot
be disproven
are not scientific in other words
something that can be proven we don't
prove things as physicists we
we don't have access to mathematical
proofs the way a mathematician does
but we have to make do with what is
presented to us in the form of evidence
and believe me peter
there are a lot of people who say there
are bubbles in physics you wouldn't know
this but
but in string theory in the multiverse
actually you tweeted today
i responded to you you tweeted about a
parallel universe and i i commend you
for for being aware of them
but some say the multiverse is true that
parallel universes exist
in space and time and space and how do
you know that that's not science well
other people say it can't be falsified
because you can't prove that there
aren't other
universes so they would say not that
it's wrong they would say it's not
scientific it's not a problem
you can't you can't disprove it right so
what would be
for you what would either falsify you
know the bitcoin what would constitute
proof that bitcoin is falsifiable and
therefore
not worthy of a teleological purpose as
money or as a store of value what would
constitute
you know well i think i think the fact
that it it has no value
in and of itself is proof that it can't
be a store of value because you can't
store what you do not have
um you know it it fails as a currency
and you've already
uh admitted that uh it doesn't work as a
currency
uh so that's you know that's
obvious uh and so then you're left with
a store of value
but if it can't ever be a currency and
that was the only supposed value it had
uh then what is what exactly are you
storing you're storing a belief
you're soaring faith i mean that's why
you have all these people
uh in the bitcoin community that you
know that don't like fiat money and i'm
glad they at least know what fiat
currency is i mean bitcoin bitcoin is
basically popularized fiat i mean
before bitcoin if you heard fiat you
thought about the automobile
i mean that was pretty much it but now
fix it again
yeah yeah but so at least they've
educated people about
the concept of fiat money versus real
money which is gold
but what they don't get is that bitcoin
is is is also fiat
even though it's not you know created by
a government
you know at the end of the day what
gives
fiat currency its value
is confidence it's faith it's my belief
that other people will accept it in the
future
if that confidence goes then it doesn't
matter what the government does it's
toast
so and that's why no fiat currency has
ever survived
they have all collapsed they all
eventually
revert to their intrinsic value which is
zero
the same thing is going to happen with
bitcoin and it doesn't matter that you
think the supply is
limited and you know of course there's
an unlimited supply of competitive
cryptocurrencies and everybody wants to
say oh they're [ __ ] coins you know they
it's i get a kick out of how everybody
is criticizing
dogecoin well you get the same thing
applies to bitcoin in fact
dogecoin is better than bitcoin i can
make it strong case
that it's superior to bitcoin even
though of course i don't recommend
either one
but the fact is there is no real
scarcity when you
when you really look down but even if
you accept the fact that there's just
there's just bitcoin and if all the
other coins go to zero because they're
worthless and bitcoins not
um it's all about confidence
it's all about people are buying bitcoin
today
because they believe somebody else will
pay more for it tomorrow
that is the only reason i'm buying it if
i no longer
have that belief then i don't want it
and if i don't want it neither does
anybody else
and since bitcoin's intrinsic value is
zero
just like fiat paper money it's fiat
digital money
when the confidence is lost so is all
the market value
so bitcoin is is fiat you know in that
sense
uh gold is not gold is real gold is
actual metal that objectively
has value it may have different value to
different people and that's what forms a
market
you know you have a a demand curve based
on people's preferences how much they
value gold versus other things
but gold has a value that can't be
denied
uh bitcoin's only value is the fact that
it might go up
i want to take a gift yeah we have a lot
of
you you're only 50 followers away from a
thousand
the inflation of peter schiff's fan base
is expanding and i take some credit for
that okay peter so i'm going to take a
question from a friend of mine
they got they also got to follow me on
twitter and youtube and
because right now right now i'm not
doing anything on on clubhouse one day i
might other than this
but yeah i think it offers a really cool
thing it has the ability to
have connection to people like you
you're a celebrity and
i'm an ordinary person but you also have
no censorship i
i found this out when i was at eric
weinstein who's an economist
he's also a physicist etc and we were
over at his house at his house for when
i went on bitcoin just a week ago
less than a week ago and he broke
through a million followers and i was
like wow and i said you know what
congratulations this means you can prove
that youtube and twitter are
a million followers on what on clubhouse
on clubhouse
who has a million follow oh oh i mean
musk no
this is eric weinstein he's a friend of
mine he's a physicist he's
i didn't even know there was that
there's that many people even on uh
clubhouse already
oh yeah there's mill there's six million
or more you have to be uninvited and
blah blah blah my point was that
the reason i think it should appeal to
youth peter is that you're probably
gonna have a big following and it may
even be bigger than the number of
followers you have on
the traditional social media networks
because they do shadow ban people like
you once you reach a certain
relevant prominence and that proved to
me when eric broke through a million
followers
in the less than six months that he was
being banned because he only has oh i
didn't even think
it's been around for that long i thought
it just literally started yeah
i resisted it because i was like do i
need another social network that has my
phone number
and like gives out all my information
anyway i want to talk to a friend who's
in nigeria
and his name is kun kun lee kun kunli
can you unmute
and uh you have a question for peter
schiff conley
[Music]
okay i'm just learning thank you okay
good from nigeria
um now uh we have other questions i'm
going to take another one i'll take this
now i know that if people who are on uh
clubhouse
once we finish this conversation it's
over on clubhouse right it's not like
recorded
but if some if somebody like missed the
beginning uh you know or they want to
tell their friends then they got to go
to youtube
youtube yeah and i'll send you the video
you can listen yeah yeah you can put it
on your youtube channel i'll send you
the video
um because i i i invented you know
parallel streaming recording to cl
or not but i like you yeah that's part
of the virtue of it because you can say
things it's not going to be recorded but
now you see the
traditional media are going against uh
clubhouse saying it's you know it's
dangerous because it's not recorded and
and the fact checkers can't check and
blah blah blah i think it's uh
i think it has a lot of vitality until
that actually happens
um okay next somebody could record it on
their own right so if you're a fact
checker
you can have your own recording device
and you can record what's happening on
clubhouse
so just because it's not being recorded
by the app doesn't mean other people
can't be reporting it on their end so
that's true that's true so i'm going to
invite someone up who's obviously
impartial
and his name is hoddle uh
uh do you want to come up on stage here
and i will invite you to be as
why do i keep i have a fat finger yeah
well you know got finger screws things
i'm hodling too i'm just huddling my
gold right so
alex how are you sir is it huddle or
hodl maybe he could tell us what to ask
i don't know let's ask him hoddle how do
you pronounce your name
i would say oh well you're guessing
though you're not even sure
he has a question for you peter go ahead
all right
young spencer uh the better [ __ ] in my
opinion
i tend to like to dunk on you on twitter
how do you feel about that
well you know obviously i i i
i don't it's not bother it doesn't
bother me because i
clearly invite a lot of it because i i
tweet a lot about
about bitcoin and i know that's gonna
ruffle feathers but you know
a lot of people don't even care it
doesn't even matter what i tweet
usually the first response is making fun
of me for bitcoin so it doesn't matter
what i tweet about
uh it's these bitcoin guys that wanna
you know i get a kick out of you know
when they tell me to have fun staying
poor
uh in case you know i ain't poor
and and you know i i don't need any
bitcoin even if it goes up i mean i'm
not going to get poor because i don't
know bitcoin i mean people keep saying
that bitcoin is going to suck away all
my wealth look
there's nothing that i own that i will
trade for bitcoin
so i got a i got a lot of stuff and if
you want my stuff
you ain't gonna get it if all you got is
bitcoin okay
i haven't taken any of it but go ahead
you'll have to go to spencer in a few
years and you know ask him
well yeah you gotta teach him about the
fifth commandment peter to okay
father honor thy father and yeah i like
it how the bitcoin community values the
uh advice of an 18 year old you know
it's like in fact i did a poll one time
on twitter
knowing what how they were gonna respond
and i was like you know
who do you want to trust an 18 year old
kid who's never had a job
or a 57 year old professional has been
working for 30 years managing money all
this experience
knowing that everybody was going to say
that i said who do you trust experienced
professional the kid
yeah and like everybody like i got so
many votes because they thought aha
we're gonna we're gonna we're gonna
hack his poll and we're all gonna vote
the kid which exactly is what i wanted
them to do because i knew they were
gonna do that
but to but to show them how ridiculous
it is
when you're young and inexperienced you
make a lot of mistakes
maybe if i was still 18 i would have
been buying bitcoin too
that's the thing it's when you're older
i'm not a dinosaur i'm not some dumb
boomer who doesn't get technology
what i get is bubbles what i get is
investments
money uh i get a i've been through a lot
of
uh bubbles i've made a lot of mistakes
i've lost a lot of money i've made a lot
of money you know
so you know i have there's some there's
value to experience
every generation thinks they know more
than the generation before them
until they get older and then they
realize how little they knew and that
their parents weren't that dumb
right now they're confronting the same
problem but you know what i have no
problem with young kids
losing money in bitcoin it's a valuable
lesson
and then when they get older and their
kids want to do something dumb
they'll be able to say listen son i
remember when i was your age and i got
all caught up in this bitcoin thing
really bitcoin what's that oh let me
tell you yeah didn't they say
but they say that the first loss is the
best loss because you get out
yeah and you know when you're young you
don't have a lot of money i i feel badly
for older people that put their
retirement money into bitcoin that's
going to be a disaster
i just put my the money for my next
week's restaurant bill
if they ever opened california you got
time for a few more questions people we
got to get
we haven't even had hotels questioned i
keep interrupting them guys hold on
that's the question i think unless the
question was am i
am i bothered by it yeah yeah and we
have another hobart we have cory
i don't want to i don't need to invite
more of it you know
i don't i don't like you know the
cursing you know or you know
no no i know i know i'm gonna ask um so
keep it keep it polite you know i got
some young people on my twitter so you
don't have to you know
that's right cory we have uh corey swann
bitcoin.com that's a very lovely name i
i don't know what uh
where in the world you get the name.com
uh corey do you wanna
ask your question to peter schiff yeah
sure so
first off welcome to clubhouse it's good
to have you on here i think it's
um it is light years ahead of twitter
as far as uh sort of keeping a sense of
decorum and sort of humanity when it
comes to debating
uh topics that can get contentious uh
and people on opposite sides of bitcoin
debates
always sort of uh tend toward being
contentious so
i think it's great that you're here i
think it'll be really interesting
kudos to brian for bringing you here and
also for being
you know probably one of the few people
that would have uh michael saylor
and peter schiff as interview subjects
within a few weeks of each other so
that's pretty cool thank you
um i also uh started what is uh
by far so far the most active uh and
most listened to
club about bitcoin on this platform and
i'm also the ceo and founder of
swanbitcoin.com
which as a business model is basically
the exact same thing as what you've been
doing with gold for
many years we just sell bitcoin how do
you sell bitcoin can anybody just buy it
why do you why do you need a salesman
you don't
we just put out youtube shows and
podcasts and spend time on clubhouse
yeah
yeah because what i actually do like at
shift gold and when i actually have to
go and buy the gold from a wholesaler
and then i turn around and i sell it
uh you know to the retail you know to
the customer but so yeah
you're just you're just educating people
i mean again from my perspective
you're indoctrinating them or
brainwashing them but anyway that's the
difference
he kept it clean so far peter peter
corey is one of the most respected
people in the bitcoin space go ahead
corey
look i like you know maybe you look i
mean there are a number of people
look i have one of my best friends here
in puerto rico
is is like so into bitcoin i mean it's
just like his life he's actually an
artist but he's more i mean he's like
you know
most of his net worth he's just a friend
of mine who lives here in puerto rico i
know a lot of bitcoin people that live
here
and this guy is very sincere i mean he
is completely 100 percent you know he
believes in it
like you know he'll huddle to zero i
mean if it actually goes to zero
this guy will go all the way down uh so
yeah you may be in the same situation
where you know you
completely believe everything you're
saying about bitcoin i i don't doubt
there are some real sincere people
that believe it but i i i i do think
there are a number of people out there
that that are saying things that they
know are not true but they're just you
know trying to pump it up
okay corey what's your question yeah go
ahead well i just i mean
i think it's you're talking a little bit
about like you know credibility and
motivations and things like that but
you know i am a pretty serious guy you
know chicago finance
mba investor for many years worked for
google and microsoft and mckenzie morgan
stanley so like i'm a serious dude
that understands bitcoin i see myself
you know essentially as a bitcoin
rationalist and my
you know my my reasons for
not just believing but actually knowing
and understanding what bitcoin is and
it's so
interesting because it really it really
is
so similar to gold in certain ways and
you know i'll even see people attacking
you on threads and saying like
you know things like you know gold is
only valuable because people
believe it's valuable and it's like well
no it's not actually gold became
the best money that we've ever had
because of specific characteristics
that gold has like it's very scarce it
has this that high stock flow ratio it
has uh
you know it's it's it doesn't degrade
it's divisible
you know yeah that's what made it good
money
but but that's not what enabled it to be
money because money needs to be
a commodity in and of itself it needs to
be just the most marketable most liquid
commodity
without the inherent value of the gold
itself those other properties that made
it so
ideal to function as money would not
have mattered i mean
in fact you know gold was already a
luxury good that people wanted
before people figured out that they
could use it as money i mean money was
kind of an invention
but gold wasn't invented gold was
discovered but the concept of money was
an invention that was an improvement on
barter
uh but i think bitcoin is a step back
because as i said right now it's more of
a barter transaction
uh but bitcoin um
does not have the most important
characteristic of gold
and that is its attributes
as an actual metal you know without that
without
without the things that you can use gold
for it it's nothing and so bitcoin is
nothing it doesn't matter if it's
if it's emulated the other things hold
on peter uh corey's got a follow-up go
ahead corey
yeah i you know there are a lot of
people that talk about you know kind of
the the monetization of an asset
and essentially the stages that you
would go through as something progressed
from let's say a collectible and then
becoming
a widely used store of value and then
moving into kind of like a medium of
exchange
and eventually being a unit of account
which would be sort of like a
full-fledged money if it fulfilled
all three of those um you know purposes
and so i think sometimes the disconnect
uh between
you know people who are really into gold
or even people that
are in the fiat fiat is great as a
medium of exchange it's awful as a store
of value
gold is awesome today as a store of
value and pretty awful
as a medium of exchange well it's not i
disagree that it's awful
as a medium of exchange i mean before
you jump in it's
well not peter
then becoming a widely used medium of
exchange and eventually you know a unit
of account
price goods services in that asset where
we
sometimes see a disconnect and i'm not
saying this is you know why you
necessarily
dislike bitcoin or don't don't subscribe
to
what we do uh but we even see that
bitcoin today
is early in its progression to becoming
a big store of value
so we believe that it being widely used
as a medium of exchange or a currency
uh is years away and eventually call it
you know 15 or 30 years whatever we'll
actually be able to uh to price goods
and services
in satoshi's the smallest unit of
bitcoin but that's decades away
right well that's that's your
speculation and i guess in order to make
that
happen there has to be a more efficient
way to produce the energy
because otherwise just the sheer cost of
of trying to effectuate all those
transactions
and validate them the amount of energy i
mean i don't even think we have the
capability even if we
didn't do anything else and devoted all
of the energy on the planet
to maintain the bitcoin network uh but
obviously
you know things could evolve in the
future but then things could evolve to
completely validate you know the whole
bitcoin
ecosystem so i i don't know but to get
back to what you're saying now about
it's proving to be a store of value
no it's not has it proven to have a
price that has appreciated well
absolutely the price has gone up
but price is not value they're very
different things in fact i tweeted
warren buffett's quote about price is
what you pay value is what you get
you can store value you can't store
price price is arbitrary it can function
around you know
based on supply and demand so
what bitcoin has proven is that people
will buy it
at higher prices but it's not been a
store of value
i mean people have
on paper gotten rich and some people in
reality because they've cashed out
some people have you know made money but
it's not storing value you know i mean
they're
i mean when you see something go you
know bitcoin just went from
ten thousand dollars when or twenty you
know ten thousand it got above ten
thousand
and then it quickly went to fifty
thousand it went five x
i mean without hyper inflation i mean if
we had seen you know
all commodities go up 5x you know at the
same time
uh and then you could have said okay
well you know but without any kind of
big increase in inflation where other
commodities maybe it went up a little
bit
that's not storing value that's a
speculative asset
that appreciated in price but
i don't see how you could take that
speculative
period of time and say this proves that
you're storing value
i mean because if i buy that today you
don't know i mean it could bitcoin can
go back down to 20 000 very quickly i
mean
can you say that you know but how can it
only count against bitcoin
that it you know it doesn't have this uh
durability this legacy this history if
indeed you agree
it's gone through some cycles it's
lasted longer than even
let's just say the most recent bubble
that we've experienced in a large
scale.com bubble
uh it lasted three or four times that
length of the actual bubble
again i i discount the the early periods
uh where you know people were mining
bitcoin on their laptops and they were
i'm saying 2018. i mean it collapses
yeah it really started in 2017
and and so we've had four years of a
roller coaster ride
where bitcoin went up to 20 000 went
down to almost 3 000
then you know had a big rally to maybe
13 14 000 then came back down to almost
3 000 again
and then had this meteoric rocket ship
ride up to 50
000 so far who knows you know maybe it
goes higher we'll see
where it ends up but i think that
there's going to be another
spectacular move down but
the at some point the move down is not
going to stop
it's going to crash for good it's not
going to be resurrected
at some point it's going to be the final
curtain on bitcoin
you know you can say no that's not gonna
happen right it's just gonna
no matter how many times it loses 70 80
90
of its value it's always going to come
back you can speculate that just because
it's come back a few times before
it's going to do it forever i i think
that's a that that that's a that's a big
gamble to take
yeah so uh corey's got a good uh yeah
corey go ahead and ask that question to
peter go ahead yeah
yeah so just as a thought exercise just
thinking about the volatility
what if we were in a world where there
was no gold
and then let's say gold appeared or an
asteroid hit
and all of a sudden there was like the
same amount of above ground gold that we
have today
what would the path be from zero
to 12 trillion would it go in a straight
line would it go
straight to 12 trillion or what are you
talking i mean the market cap the price
of gold
understand what the values and what was
good about gold and started to
understand okay maybe i like this thing
maybe i want to buy more of it
would it would it basically have a
volatile path
to reaching look you're i mean you're
asking a crazed hypothetical because
there's no way to just drop
all the gold i mean are you talking
about is the gold now
in the earth or do we now have all the
gold already mined
sitting in bars we're actually watching
the monetization of bitcoin
in real time right now we've been
watching it you know we are not watching
the monetization of
anything all we're watching is a
speculative bubble in a digital token
it is not being monetized nowhere on the
planet earth
is bitcoin used as money so we haven't
seen anything
when you show me a future where
salaries are in bitcoin rents are in
bitcoin
there's a bitcoin bond market there are
insurance policies that pay off in
bitcoin
where governments are collecting tax
bitcoin well you show me a world or even
a country
that actually uses bitcoin as money
where people accept bitcoin not because
they want it but because they want to
buy something else with it
you show me that and i'll say okay it's
we're seeing the beginning of money
all we have right now is a speculative
digital token that people are buying and
huddling
that's it it's no more money than beanie
babies
right it's the same thing it's no more
money than tulips
yeah go ahead corey go ahead one more
time so peter corey's hasn't finished
his actual statement yet so hold on
we'll take this and then we'll take a
couple more go ahead corey
now so listen
the facts on the ground are that we are
watching the monetization
of bitcoin over time it will reduce in
volatility that's what you hope
you're not watching that maybe you're
seeing that but that's not what you're
actually watching your
your your judgment is clouded so you
it's an illusion
the trends are that volatility is
reducing
no it's not it's still very vital look
look it went up to 50 000 this morning
and then dropped to 47
000. i mean within an hour i mean even
even in there
i mean it's much more vital than and and
we just recently had a big drop
we had just what a few weeks ago or a
month ago we had like a 30
30 drop in a couple of days it went from
um
what like forty thousand down to like
twenty seven thousand like you know in a
day
sure yeah yeah okay so here's the yeah
go for it corey so corey's got a
response to the volatility go ahead
well i was actually gonna go back and we
should try to hit like one topic at a
time because
now i want to go back to the energy bank
uh
do you believe in free markets including
a free market for energy
heater yeah i believe in free markets
i'm not trying to outlaw bitcoin
i mean people want to buy it go ahead
i'm not saying you can't
so what is your worry if people freely
choose to mine
bitcoin using computers that use energy
do you think oh no no i just
i'm just commenting that it's a waste of
resources people are allowed to waste
resources but
you know as a human being you know i
mean we i try to recycle i mean we do
all kinds of stuff here i mean my wife
is more on it than i am but all of our
baskets we make sure
we put things you know so i'm trying to
conserve energy
i'm trying to do stuff like that that's
why i thought it was ironic you know
that tesla you know they get
they got 1.5 billion dollars in
environmental credits
for helping to reduce you know the
carbon because of their
electric cars and i ordered an electric
car i got and i got a high so i got two
really
um uh but then they go ahead and they
buy bitcoin which is
squandering all sorts of electricity uh
so yeah i'm not saying it should be
illegal to waste resources i
you know i i just think it's a shame
that we're wasting all those resources
that's all
do you think it's maybe let's say okay
if bitcoin succeeds and obviously a lot
of people think it's already succeeding
today
is it worth some level of
expenditure to have state free money
that can't be confiscated by the people
with the guns
and the power the way that go well i
don't think it's money i don't think
it's state free and i don't think it
can't be confiscated
i mean it's on the internet it lives on
the internet it's much harder to
confiscate gold
uh i mean if the government has been
confiscated peter we have no
actually okay so it wasn't confiscated
what roosevelt did
and the reason that they did it is
because he wanted to value the dollar
because when roosevelt asked americans
to turn in their gold
uh it was 20 dollars an ounce and after
he got the gold he devalued the dollar
and now gold was 35
in order to do this he had to get
everybody's gold but they didn't
send troops to people's homes and shake
them down for their gold
they just said if you have any gold you
bring it in but they didn't
and penalty of arrest right i mean hold
on
lots of people did not turn in their
gold that's why there's still
so many gold coins around today because
the ones that got turned in got melted
down
so a lot of people kept their gold and
nothing happened to them in fact nobody
went to jail for not turning in their
gold
so it wasn't like you know but if they
tried to
get your bitcoin it'd actually be a lot
easier to get your computer records and
find out oh you know that you you have
some bitcoin
but if the government really wanted to
outlaw bitcoin they could do it very
easily uh i i don't think they're doing
it because they're not afraid of bitcoin
i mean if they actually thought there
was a lot of money laundering or tax
evasion going on
that would bother them they don't think
it's a threat
to their monetary system to their fiat
monetary system if they
did they would have already shut it down
uh that's why i said a long time ago
that even if bitcoin succeeded
it would be a victim of its own success
because the government would kill it
but i think it's going to die of natural
causes i don't think the government has
to kill it
because all they have to do is outlaw it
and nobody then it's then you drive it
into the black market and then
there's no there's no real use there so
peter good news and bad news uh we still
you've gotten up over a thousand
followers on clubhouse mazel tov on that
uh corey has one last uh comment and i
want to take some more questions
all right but i got i got to do my own
podcast let's get late i got a podcast
today
if peter does want to talk to a few more
bitcoins like
just a couple of people from the
audience that are kind of known to the
community but i don't know that i'm
going to hear anything i haven't heard
i mean you know you know what i i
obviously i wish somebody had convinced
me to buy it years ago because i would
have bought some
but the problem is i i've heard i've
heard these arguments
from so many people for so many years i
haven't heard anything new
but yes i agree that the whole time i've
been saying it can't work it's not money
it's a bubble the entire time the price
has been going up
and i've been there before that happened
with the real estate bubble
it happened with this.com bubble i've
been in that position before
i've seen it all happen before i know
how the movie ends
this one is particularly frustrating
though because of the nature of it
and the type of people who are buying it
so i think the bitcoin bubble is more
frustrating to me than the housing
bubble or dot-com bubble
um and i think it's even more irrational
too so it's you know all right let's
take one more thing from corey and then
uh corey and then i'm going to finish up
because peter's got to go do his own
pockets get going last one yeah i mean
what i would say is
you know peter happy to talk to you on
this platform again
in the future i think it would make a
lot of sense uh obviously got to get you
with a better uh
audio setup and i think you've had a lag
for a lot of this so
if people are listening and think that
peter has been
rudely talking over people i think it's
actually more of an
audio delay yeah but i'm actually a
little rude too sometimes that's one of
my
faux pas listen man you're not gonna
bother me
uh i do want to address this idea that
it's uh you know
one bitcoin is transmitted over the
internet but it's actually a ledger and
so you could turn off the internet
and people would still have copies of
the ledger on you know yes i i get that
aspect of it but obviously if people
only have
if if your bitcoin is just on a piece of
paper or in your mind because you've
memorized
the whole thing uh it obviously has a
lot less value
to the people who want it than if you
could you know transmit it through the
internet
because if they make it illegal and you
know i mean it's going to be very tough
to use
to use it online when the government is
you know seeing everything we do
well actually that's a positive thing i
think cory um yeah so
one thing i would say is actually the
the claim that it's been used for all
these illegal purposes and so forth it's
actually
pales and comparison to the us dollars
use and the legal purposes in the black
market section yeah
but the problem is you can't you can't
catch those if i give somebody an
envelope full of 100 bills i mean unless
you physically
watch me do it they're i mean they don't
know that i've done it
but if i'm going to send you bitcoin
over the internet
i mean there's going to be a trail
they're you know so
yeah i mean it actually protects it
against being used in black markets and
who on the black market
but yeah but the black market is
actually that is one of the only use
cases that when i first heard about it
right way back when
the only thing that seemed to have some
value to me was you know
if it really is anonymous even if it's
pretty volatile
and you lose 20 or 30 percent of the
value during transactions
that's not a bad price to pay to launder
your money
because you know you launder your money
the old-fashioned way it cost a lot i
mean they take you know
20 cents 30 cents 40 cents i mean you
earn a dollar illegally
and you have people launder it for you
yeah i mean there's not a lot you know a
lot of it comes out of the wash
so i thought originally when i heard
about bitcoin it was like yeah that
would be the
you know it's a way for me to transfer
money uh
over a long distance not the money but
value because i can
buy some bitcoin send you the bitcoin
you can sell it
and even if you lose 10 20 who cares
you've got this laundered transaction no
nobody can spy on you i snuck money out
of the country
so i thought that was the value of it
initially but i wasn't you know i wasn't
gonna buy it
based on the fact that i thought there
was some value for
you know people that wanted to launder
money but you know also i know that you
know i don't like the government
i mean look i the government is spying
on everybody i hate that
right not the fact that the government
is a lot of compatriots in that way
all right corey last one because there's
a ton of people that want to ask
questions go ahead last question
i was gonna actually just uh see my spot
and i was just gonna recommend to you
if you wanted to grab uh john he looks
like he's in the fourth row first slot
followed by speakers that's john ballast
he's a a great libertarian
big appreciation for gold thanks peter's
done over the years i think
a worthy conversation okay good all
right john i'm following you now i'll
get to your question in just a second
peter you got five ten more minutes is
that okay
all right yeah i got what i got one
point one thousand followers no it's
going up we got a thousand people
but there's still not many you can you
know no no you you have now
you'll you'll have the logarithm of the
number of followers of mark andreessen
very soon
or of uh you know uh any of the any of
the tick tock pioneers that are on this
platform
all right john you have the stage i'm
going to invite you
up let's see john if i can do this
following you john ballas uh
let me see hold him down and yeah so
please
come up and follow peter on here follow
his uh twitter handle is
uh peter schiff go to europe pacific
capital peter schiff shift gold i
yeah i got all those you could basically
start living just some bitcoin guy got
my handle on uh
on um a clubhouse and i had to be i had
to be peter shift one
all right this is a real leadership you
can hear his voice it's grappling from
years of yelling at spencer
okay john are you uh willing to come up
if he isn't i there's plenty of others
that will take his place
uh but i want to ask you uh while we're
waiting for john to come up john just
button whenever you're up on stage there
you are
john go ahead john valace everybody
john can you hear me
can you get closer to the phone uh john
it's i just hear i think you're far away
from the microphone i can't hear you
just give me one second okay yeah so
peter they got to come up to the stage
get their check yeah let's hurry up
because not only i do
my podcast but at this point i got to
use the bathroom yeah i know we need to
give peter a bio break
john let me know in your back and then i
got a couple of times better that's much
better go ahead
all right sweet um peter thanks for
doing this you know as
these conversations have happened a lot
in the past and
it always seems like uh the bitcoin side
and you are talking past each other
and you know there's many different
elements of
of this subject that we can you know
zero in on and have a debate about but
i'm just curious kind of like on a more
macro level
what would it take for you to treat the
people that you're
engaging with as if they understood
something
that you do not yet understand what
would it take in the form of
a type of debate or respect for the
other person or
what would it take for you to treat
someone as if they know something that
you don't is basically my question
well i don't know like what do they know
that i don't know i mean
i don't know that they know something
about money or about economics that
they did know something you don't know
what would it take for that to happen
yeah it's sort of the falsifiability
question i asked you earlier
i mean look there are look the gold or
your hypothesis
look there are a lot of people that own
bitcoin that know a lot more about
computers and programming
and and and a lot of stuff that relates
to bitcoin that i don't know right i
mean they're gonna you know i mean if
you had an exam on bitcoin i mean look i
i lost my bitcoin i mean how much did i
know
now of course the guy that set up my
wallet for me
never told me about my private key he
never told me my password all he gave me
uh was a a a a pin and that's eric
voorhees who i just you know
you know and he's like oh he knows so
much about it hey dude why don't you
give me my
password you know you set up my wallet
you know oh you know you just
when i asked well i assumed you would
create a different wallet why assume
that
i had the wallet you set up for me but
um so yeah
my my bitcoiner lost in cyberspace
not that i had that many i didn't even
have a whole coin i had about a third of
a coin but now obviously it's worth it
so john has one uh one follow-up john
and then we can move on go ahead john
yeah sure i i'll just finish by saying
this i think this illustrates a great
point
and i think oftentimes outside of this
debate and of course within it
our hubris our ego our assumption that
we already know
everything there is to know about a
thing will keep us from actually
understanding what's required to know
about it
in order to understand it and i think
when peter mentions
you know how he's interacted with the
coins he was given in the past and his
quote-unquote password
and when i hear him speak about this
subject it's very clear to me
that he has not taken the time to really
do the work and i assume that's because
he's dismissed it
before he's given you know he's already
made oh
[Music]
i haven't look i i i gave it a serious
look i thought about it seriously when i
first
when i first look when i first heard
about it and it was i don't know around
ten dollars i can't remember
exactly where it was and i was like you
know
all right but what's to stop somebody
else from coming up with another
cryptocurrency
because back then that was it maybe
there was litecoin i don't know if
there's
a couple others or maybe it was only
bitcoin um
but um i looked at it
and i just said look this isn't going to
work um
for all the reasons i still think it's
not gonna work then
when you had that big move where bitcoin
all of a sudden went from 200 to a
thousand
and people started talking about it and
then it pulled back
over a couple years i actually thought
about buying it
i mean i thought about buying it not
because i thought it was going to work
but because i was just looking at the
chart and i was saying i don't know
maybe this thing's going to have another
run
i mean i just looked at it as a
technical guy
and then i would and then that's why i
said but you know [ __ ] i didn't want to
buy it at ten dollars why the hell am i
gonna buy it at two or three hundred i
had a
that was my emotional problem back then
because i had rejected it
at a really really low price right and i
was like well now i'm going to pay this
much
and gamble that it's going to go up i
was like why i mean and so
then i just i didn't want to do it but i
still
my re my the reason i thought about
doing it back then
was not because i thought it was going
to work i thought it would i thought it
could rally and then crash again
and i've never believed that it was
going to work
no matter how much i learned about it no
matter how much people told me about it
i still think they're wrong i still
think that
it's never going to deliver on its
promise
but what it has delivered is a big gain
for anybody who bought it
and i don't know how much longer this is
going to continue
you know because it's obviously you know
gone on for a long time
and you know a lot of people that
initially made fun of it
have actually gotten involved and some
of that because they think they can make
money off it some of these banks that
now see money like they can be made off
of bitcoin even if they don't
necessarily believe in it they believe
they can make money off it yeah
so well peter yeah i know you you've
been very gracious and generous for your
time there's millions of questions i
recommend that you do more now you've
got
i i like to over promise and over
deliver peter
now you've got 1.1 000 followers on
clubhouse i recommend that you just do
this you open it up every now and then
and then uh you'll get uh you'll get
some bio but you get some amazing
conversations that really
in some cases like bring tears to my
eyes talk about god and religion on this
channel
we talk about cosmonauts i i really
haven't explored my
uh you like it yet i mean i signed up
and and that was about it you like it
now you've got a lot of costs sunk into
it so let's go to the final questions i
ask everybody
on the into the impossible podcast who
honors me i've had billionaires like
yourself jim simons peter i'm not a
billionaire yet
peter diamandis all right well the first
i'm getting closer though i'm getting
closer
the first billion is the hardest take it
from me no i don't really know that yeah
i can imagine yeah
although what i mentioned earlier i
mentioned earlier on the day you know
that
that um ray dalio you know was
followed me on on this yeah and maybe he
listens to my podcast because he
followed me the day after
i mentioned it on my podcast but he only
follows six people
and i'm the only one that's not a
billionaire and so so yeah i mean
i guess i'm in good company when it
comes so hopefully hopefully within a
few years i'll
i'll be able to be on that list of
billionaires
yeah well you know yeah maybe i would
already be there if i bought some
bitcoin but
yeah that's it that's too easy i'm not
gonna go there but i ask all my guests
to come on the end of the impossible
ask these three questions and they're
kind of deep philosophical questions we
covered all the stuff
you've been very generous but i want to
ask you the following first question
which is looking into the future when
you reach the biblical age of 120 that
moses himself
died at before getting into the promised
land i always point out
he left what's called an ethical will
though alfred
uh nobel did the same thing i talk about
this in my book losing the nobel prize
alfred nobel
left the will to because he had no wife
no children no
no ex-wives and he gave all his money
basically this prize
but and uh and it had to do with an
ethical
implication that you should not only do
things in science for its own purpose
that you should do things uh for the
benefit of all mankind i want to ask you
peter
when you uh reach the age of 120 and you
depart this mortal coil
what ethical wisdom what what wisdom not
monetary wisdom now
what are monetary bequeathments or or um
for your monetary heirs what do you want
to leave the world
in terms of wisdom that you've gleaned
in your life
well you know first of all i hope that
if i can live to 120
at some point they will discover some
way to
euthane me or clone me or do something
that i could end up living even longer
than that
uh you know uh so yeah because a lot
could happen
you know i'm not gonna be 120 for a
while yeah so
uh if i can make it to that age you
never know maybe i can make it to a
thousand so
you know what do you have there's
probably a better chance of that than
bitcoin becoming uh
money in the world um not everything has
to be about bitcoin though don't worry
look i like i i certainly hope that i
leave the world
uh in a better place
uh not this so that i found it but that
the world is better because i was a part
of it you know we're all here
for a very short period of time and and
then we're gone
right um and and so to the extent that
we could do something
that endures beyond our lifetime um
i mean that's rare i mean most people
are forgotten
uh when the last person that remembered
them dies
i mean that they interacted with i mean
that's what happens i mean to everybody
except those rare individuals that
manage to achieve
something where their name and their
legacy goes on
and and you know and so yeah i mean i i
would hope that that would happen
uh to me that you know people will look
back on me and i think
now i mean now it's a lot easier because
obviously
uh there's not that many people from a
thousand years ago 500 years ago
but a thousand years from now it's gonna
be very easy
to know what we were doing back back in
the day
because it's all there yeah i mean all
this data is not going anywhere i mean
you want to find something
from a thousand years ago you got to dig
it up you're going to be an
archaeologist so you got to find
something i didn't hear their voice you
can't see their their face can you
imagine like
can you imagine like you know we have
history classes today and we only have i
mean we have ancient history there's not
that much but you know you have
modern history but can you imagine in a
thousand years having to go to a history
class
all the stuff you got to learn because
there's so much information that
a thousand years of computers right
although maybe by then
we won't have to learn anything we'll
just upload all the data right into a
chip in our heads
and so we'll just know everything right
all this everything that's been done
we'll we'll
be there yeah i hope that you know
my grandchildren or great grandchildren
will
be able to say yeah you know talk about
their dad and maybe even
my dad too maybe i mean i think my dad
could live on for
the things that he did i mean i didn't
invent anything i mean i'm not somebody
that you know i didn't come up with some
revolution i
invention you know i didn't cure any
disease you know but but i think i did
help
educate a lot of people you know i get a
lot of emails still today
uh from the occupy wall street video i
did you know it's got
millions and millions i just put it up
on my channel a few years ago and i got
over four million views
but it's got a lot more than that from
the original reason
but i mean i think i've helped a lot of
people evolve
uh you know uh in their political uh
beliefs
uh you know going from socialist to free
market
and so i think you know that's kind of
you know more than what i'm trying to do
now as far as
in my business trying to help people
preserve their wealth
in you know from what i think is coming
a major collapse of the dollar
major inflation potentially
hyperinflation so
i think there's a lot of wealth that's
going to be lost taxed away to inflation
and so i'm trying to help people but i
mean that's thousands of people that i'm
helping maybe tens of thousands but
there are millions and millions of
people that i can influence with
knowledge
you know and get them to understand um
and so yeah i mean hopefully
you know that will that will endure
uh but you know the problem the problem
you know you look back
when it comes to science it seems that
we we always build upon
you know what prior generations
accomplished right we don't have to
start from scratch right we don't
when we if you're a mathematician if
you're a physicist
you don't have to start from day one
reinventing all these
everything that was learned you've got
from a thousand
right but in economics it's it's crazy
because it's like we always
every every generation starts from zero
it's like they completely forgot all the
experience
of their ancestors and they just make
all the same mistakes i mean the
knowledge
you know we're not any smarter than we
were hundreds of years ago
as a society so it would be nice if that
were to change because we could have
tremendous progress
if the world could reject socialism once
and for all
and never go back never repeat a failed
experiment
you know that would be a milestone in
human achievement uh because you know
imagine
if we could have maintained in america
the same type of economic freedom that
we had
you know let's say at the end of the
19th century if government had gotten no
bigger than it was then
and we enjoyed the same amount of
economic freedom imagine the world that
we would live in today i mean i
you can't because it would be it would
be it was it would be so spectacular
compared to what what we got now it's
funny in science there i'll joke
nobel prize winner max planck said
physics or science advances one funeral
at a time
but even though marx you know by the way
marx was the object one of the objects
of karl popper's derision so we talked
earlier about falsification hypothesis
testing astrology
and so forth but you know i always point
out you know he hated
popper hated astrology and marxism
dialectic materialism
uh because he claimed they couldn't be
falsified because he'd always say well
this time is different in marxism you
know
we're always going to relearn these
lessons again and again and i like to
point out that there's a lot more
astrology columnists and astrologers in
the world than astronomers
and there's a lot more marxists than
than capitalists and so
i feel like popper himself has been
fulfilled in a sense but i want to go to
the next question
which also takes us into the future and
so i am the co-director here i thought
that was the last question that we just
had
oh uh sorry i got two more i got two
more quick ones i feel
like my problem is my answers aren't
quick i really gotta get out of it no i
love it but you know
people she will tune into the uh to the
peter schiff show and you'll listen to
yeah my my podcast is gonna start late
because i still got to start recording
okay all right so last one i'll i'll do
the last one then peter okay
so i like to i'm the co-director of the
arthur c clarke center for human
imagination at uc san diego
and we like to talk about the different
laws that arthur c clarke
said one of which you might have heard
before we opened every podcast with it
and it's that any sufficiently advanced
technology is indistinguishable from
magic
the second law or the next law is that
for every
expert there's an equal and opposite
expert
and the third law is the only way of
discovering the limits of the possible
is to venture a little way past them
into the impossible and that's how i
came up with the name of the podcast so
i want to ask you peter what in your
life was mysterious as a 20 year old a
30 year old
but makes sense to you now because you
had the courage
to go into the impossible i was about to
answer your question until you said
it makes sense to me now because i was
going to say women
and and i they didn't make sense to me
then and they still don't make sense to
me i think i may
know a little bit more about them but
they're still a bit of a mystery
um but look i mean
i don't really know beyond that i mean
you know my dad kind of put me on the
right you know
path early in life when it comes to
economics and so
you know i didn't have that journey from
you know being a socialist to
discovering
you know free markets and i've been
libertarian iran you know
all my life so that's just been my uh my
perspective but look i'm not
venturing into you know fantasyland
because
that's what i think happened with
bitcoin right i just think it's all
you know i i i'm here in reality i'm not
living in this fantasy world
uh where i think uh people are there i
mean i mean in fact not just fantasy i
mean people there
you know i mean they're a crazy town
you know and i you know i i'm just not
going there you know
um okay so you you could try you could
try to coax me in
you know you had sailor on there and he
had his an analogy of an igloo
he come on in this great igloo and then
he said peter schiff is out there saying
yeah yeah stay out of that igloo you
know like
like you know um you know
the the he i think he probably had the
analogy backwards or
you know um but it's that that this is
crazy
that's crazy town is where is where
they're trying to
they're trying to get people all right
well i do want to thank you
uh you've had a great influence on on me
i don't agree but that's okay we can
always agree to this i agree with
everything you say i listen
religiously to your podcast i follow you
and everybody should on twitter now on
clubhouse thanks to me i'm
hurting my back my shoulder patting
myself on the back you know thank you so
much for the courage you've displayed
throughout the years
you've been very prescient on some
things and some things you uh
you you've had a challenging record on
but i do salute your
your courage and your honesty and your
integrity
to uh to talk to people who differ with
you and i and i hope this was done in a
respectful manner and
we'll stay around clubhouse for those
that want to chat i have to go to my
eighth pod eighth
podcast eighth eighth zoom call of the
day peter thank you so much i hope you
can do a part two something maybe would
you be willing to come on with michael
saylor if i can arrange it
i mean i suppose as i said it'd be great
if we could hook ourselves up to those
lie detectors okay well i
mean some of these things seem like i
don't know he seems like a smart guy i'm
like how could he actually believe that
so i i get you know i you know so that
that would be the interesting thing
okay but yeah you know i mean i i you
know i might be willing to do that
uh we'll see but um you know but thank
you
if you want if you want a part two just
split this one up into two parts because
i think it's
plenty long very good peter thank you so
much
i'll stick around clubhouse hope to see
you in the club again and again all
right
take care and yes you were very polite
and respectful